l'épisode de cette semaine est
commandité par jus frais vous l'aurez
deviné c'est une compagnie qui offre des
jus frais sains service de commande en
ligne donc vous commandez vos jeux ils
sont faits le soir même et vous sont
livrés le lendemain philippe le
fondateur de la compagnie ne nous porte
et des jeux à l'appart qu'on peut se les
tester puis honnêtement j'étais très
impressionné par la qualité des jumeaux
faingaa qui boit beaucoup de jus dans
vie parce que je trouve ça goûte souvent
chimiques mais là ce n'est pas du tout
le cas
gros char heurte au jus de pomme j'avais
l'impression de sortir du verger avec
une pomme dans mes mains puis de la même
dans un blender plus à bord ce trade up
c'est sûr que leurs commandes y avait
même un café froid
moi je tends grands consommateurs de
café fait que c'est sûr que j'en
recommande était excellent et offre un
service de livraison à coup stable donc
ces quatre dollars si vous êtes dans les
environs de montréal sinon évidemment si
vous sortez des environs de montréal
c'est selon les taux de postes canada
mais dans l'est un jour ouvrable donc
c'est quand même beau jeu et fait la
veille que vous le recevez ayant un
rabais de 8 dollars offre sur 60 $ et
plus donc vous êtes malgré tout pas
obligé d'en commander % en europe peut
commander injuste si vous voulez
l'essayer il n'y a aucune limite
inférieur ni supérieur et on a même un
code promo pour vous qui est le sf 10
lors du check out de votre première
commande pour 10 % de rabais sur votre
commande donc allé voir sur leur site
jus frais points c'est à étudier le code
promo sf 10 pour 10 % rabais donc merci
à la galerie de cheese jus frais puis on
vous le recommande quant à l'épisode de
cette semaine est également présentée
par l'électronique cycling association
1er arr qui est un organisme à but non
lucratif axée sur la réutilisation de
matériels électroniques désuets
pourquoi réutiliser au lieu de recycler
o2 jeter c'est simplement qu'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui ont pas les moyens
de s'acheter du matériel informatique
qui pourrait très bien bénéficier du
matériel dont se sert pu pourquoi il ya
des gens qui hésitent à donner au
prochain avec les matériels
électroniques c'est surtout pour la
sécurité des données dont nous y mettons
voulez donner votre ordinateur
si vous voulez pas que la personne qui
leur soit vraiment c'est que des photos
de vous et vos chiens mais le ra offre
un service d'effacement et de
destruction physique des données dont
vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir peur de
tout durant là que vides ils ont mis en
place une campagne pour aider les gens
qui se trouvaient sur les étudiants et
les travailleurs qui se retrouvent à
devoir faire leurs études ou leur
travail de la maison qu'ils avaient pas
les moyens d'avoir un équipement adéquat
pour faire ce est là pour la rentrée qui
s'en vient et offre plusieurs concours
pour gagner soit des bourses d'études du
matériel électronique pour les étudiants
donc vous pouvez avoir plus
d'informations sur le 1er à pointis et à
lyon si vous voulez en fait planifier
une cueillette ou avoir plus
d'information fait également les appeler
au 1 8 7 7 9 3 9 2 7 8 3 on va mettre le
tout ces informations là dans la
destruction du podcast donc si vous avez
du matériel chez vous électronique que
vous vous servez plus et que vous voulez
jusqu'au paiement impôts jetés et que ça
serve à quelqu'un qui en a possiblement
besoin à lecce questeur au ra point ca
ou appelez au numéro que j'ai mentionné
un petit peu plus tôt qui va être écrit
dans la description du podcast sur ce
bon podcast production du f bienvenue au
sans filtre le podcast où on parle de ce
qu'on veut que nos invités date si tu
peux quentin avec moins d'hommes plantes
on vient tout juste d'enregistrer le
encore moins de filtres donc si vous
voulez entendre des conversations
exclusive à nos membres et nous risquons
discutent du podcast qu'on vient
d'enregistrer dirigez vous vers peut
tuer en trois pièces par mois relève
accès à touches contenus exclusifs là et
vous avez accès à tous les podcasts
aussi en ligne avant même qu'ils sortent
sur toutes les autres plateformes donc
dirigez vous vers pétillant le lien dans
l'addition du podcast ci nomme cette
semaine
cette semaine vraiment content de
recevoir des filles éduquées
journalistes spécialisés en des
informations et en théorie du complot et
tout ce qu'on peut lire de louche sur
internet et y est journaliste à
l'émission les décrypteurs à radio
canada écrit des articles aussi
c'est ce pas intéressant parle avec lui
on a parlé de plus loin plein d'affaires
de ce phénomène le des fausses nouvelles
en général des réseaux sociaux
commencent à se propage coiffard qu'on
connaît quelqu'un qui tombe un petit peu
là dedans que quoi faire quand nous
mêmes on on sait pas démystifier
départager le vrai du faux
quelle est la responsabilité des réseaux
sociaux est là dedans on a parlé
beaucoup 6 2 le mouvement qu un dunk
d'un mouvement conspirationnistes qui
prend beaucoup d'ampleur est assez
inquiétant des cons et on a essayé de
comprendre ce qui fait que c'est
vraiment une super belle conversation
qui est un gars qui connaît son sujet
jusqu'au bout les doigts ouais c'est
important d'écouter la conversation
c'est important de savoir reconnaître
les signes avant-coureurs de genre de
choses je le prouverai cc je pense que
tu l'a bien dit inquiétant étant le mot
à utiliser restez à l'affût comme dirait
victoria charlton garder l'oeil ouvert
puis dalphond partagez le les
commentaires le soyez mollo ces
commentaires qui risque d'avoir du monde
qui sont pas d'accord avec avec ce qu'on
dit qu'ils vont durer les commentaires
éventuellement mais écoutez cc on est
sur youtube c'est la vie donc partager
votre impression de la conversation
comme job thoms down si vous aimez pas
ce petit marc pado si vous aimez pas ça
fait de ce rien dire
pis dans le fond a partagé par hasard ou
d'amis sans plus attendre bon podcast
bonne écoute
[Musique]
yes merci beaucoup d'être là mais merci
délectation fait plaisir on pourrait
commencer par un million d'endroits
cette session la dans les derniers jours
sachant contre qu'on allaite recevoir en
faisant des recherches
j'avais l'impression moi même de tomber
dans un espèce de rabbit hole de
conspiration pis comment est ce que
quand c'est fait partie intégrante de
ton métier puis de ce que tu fais
comment tu restes un esprit dans tout ce
je m'entraîne vol et le flou très
pendant la pandémie c'est assez intense
et on a tous dans l'équipe du prof d'éco
j'étais vraiment pour notre bien-être
personnel s'est exposé constamment un
environnement qui super ans qui a
rejoint les conspirations ces affaires
la cgem est positif c'est jamais jambes
le gouvernement travaille en secret pour
vous exactement c'est vraiment cessé
tout en suspens négatif sur tout un
trader ça vient de l'anxiété des gens
aussi les gens ce que racontent des
conspirations s'y exprime une crainte ou
l'anxiété qu'ils vivent le t71 inciter
leurs livrets puis la commune équipe i
quand tu viens démentir ce bel hôtel
ennemis auront perçu pendant la pandémie
5,6 menace de mort non à nos courriels
si c'était quelque chose mais jamais ça
fait quasiment six ans que je couvre la
désinformation quand tu a démenti des
choses
les gens sont souvent pas content que
tous les contrats dits métier j'avais
déjà reçu des messages un peu fort
schiste est habitué mais le niveau
d'agressivité quelque chose qu'on
n'avait jamais vu avant fake c'est sûr
que ça a affecté vraiment tout le monde
c'est tous les journalistes en général
ça laisse à les affecter le ca tandis
que contre la population
mais nous c'est sûr qu'on a eu droit à
un concentré en concentré de toutes ces
choses que je vous donnais une ville
avant la pandémie on savait quatre ou
cinq courriels par jour de jean qui est
comme jeep sort qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
est ce que c'est vrai dans le gros de la
pandémie en avril mystère de 120-130 par
jour puis ça a été la première les deux
premières semaines après le début du
confinement 15 mars à peu près je
regardais ma inbox puisse arriver juste
pas de bon sens j'allais me faire un
café je revenais j'avais trente messages
de plus jeté comme une caisse qui
faisait se concentrer leurs skis c'est
juste le fait que le mans se questionner
plus serait sur la situation acquis dans
quel vin est témoin du pilote
automatique puis prenez le temps
d'essayer des écoutes c'est vraiment son
on assiste en parallèle à un véritable
phénomène de société
il ya des gens qui dépeint des
observateurs qui s'inquiètent depuis un
bout de gens de apocalypse de
l'information de crise qui
débarqueraient ou dangeraux la même
personne c'est qu'est ce qui est vrai il
ya des parallèles qui se créent pis
cette cause la division ça cause
beaucoup de stress dans la société
c'est ce qu'on a vu thales le scénario
le night meilleur scénario le viewty
mettant en partance à vis de crainte
qu'ils sont tout à fait
je suis légitimiste et toutes nos vies
ont été changés moi même quand la
distanciation social a été mis en place
qu'est ce que moi je vis ma vie et
chaque côté ce qu'elle va pouvoir l
épicerie dans deux semaines pour avoir
ma blonde dans un mois si on voyait
qu'est ce qui se passe en france en
italie stress l'a fait en sorte que les
gens sont parfois plus portés à croire
peu n'importe quoi
d'une part je ne veux pas il ya des gens
qui exploitent
c'était des gens qui se disent bon ben
il réalise qu'un auditoire aller
chercher avec ce soit qui sont eux mêmes
convaincus de toutes ces conspirations
l'appui je sais c'est aller chercher un
sport avec ça où il y en a qui sont
carrément cynique je suspecte le pis
qu'ils disent bon bain garde
il voit le vent tourner puis décidé
d'accrocher leurs cerfs volants les
chercher la traction sur des réseaux
sociaux avec ce dont doute yves dans un
contexte où tout le monde pose les
questions
la situation évolue et chaque trait au
début ce dès les masques c'est pas
nécessaire on grandit fo partie des
masses tout le temps quand on est en
public
les symptômes semblent changer le au
début mais ça fait pas les enfants l'ont
et puis ça fait que les enfants une
pandémie comme ça c'est normal que les
choses évoluent rapidement tes les
scientifiques de ça lui prend des années
à venir
on a compris mais c'est à l'intérieur de
quelques mots avec le les gens entendent
des informations complètement contraires
sont complètement perdus là dedans puis
il y en a qui tombe dans comme tadic
dans ses vitraux pis sa cause devant le
plus comme un effet de rentrer donc
peut-être commencer bon moi je pense que
le virus et écrire en laboratoire dont
chercher l'information là tu l'autre
tombé sur une vidéo youtube qui ne
baisse pas juste car mon virus qui est
écrit en laboratoire le sida aussi a été
créé en laboratoire tous leurs concerts
rentrer là dedans puis youtube et ben
trop enclin d'autres montré des vidéos
qui vont kit rassemble ce soit qui vont
plaire qui vont plaire facebook vote
suggérer des groupes
vous feriez vous ferez l'expérience
aller dans des groupes facebook
conspirationnistes vous allez voir vos
recommandations et dieu serait pas juste
ça ils ont fait le ménage là-dedans mais
disons que cette machine l'a offert en
sorte que les conspirations qui avant
rejoignez des petits groupes de
personnes quand même assez hermétique
les gains des trippeux de conspiration
sur reddit des gagnants des gens avec
qui créent des petites chambres
conspirationnistes sur youtube un petit
auditoire vraiment de très peu de
conspiration ben la pandémie fait en
sorte que ce contenu lui a été montré au
bout ce qui fut justement de rester
phénomène le de fausses nouvelles puis
des conspirations parlement quand et
comment c'est justement couvrir sur le
genre de métro dans le tas l'ambiance
était vraiment marginal c'est quasiment
une curiosité que ce soit drôle farfelu
ut de checker se dit aujourd'hui plus
rien de drôle là dedans c'est réellement
inquiété mercredi
des fois je retourne vont m'aimer
premier billet d'inspecteurs avec le jeu
métro c'était vraiment ça écrit sur un
ton un peu sarcastique
je m'en moque disons que ç'a pris ne
tournera pas mal plus depuis quelques
années ça c'est certain
un bon exemple c'est la 5 gilles des
années on le sait qu'il ya des gens qui
bon certaines réserves envers la 5g on
parle de ce disque est ce à cause des
problèmes de santé quelconque leur carte
si ça existe et on envoyait des petits
groupes sur facebook qui procès
d'utiliser les les conspirations soit 5
g un pilote pendant la pandémie
on s'est mis à avoir énormément de
contenu en rapport avec la 5g de kehl à
5,6 quel chrono virus dans le fond
c'était existait pas c'est la 5g des
symptômes d'empoisonnement aux autres
sans que j'y étais j'ai fait
l'expérience à les voir sur google
trends jeudi mais sans que j'aie un peu
recherche le king mal à s'arrêter normal
si par exemple on avait annoncé et qu'on
étend le 5 juin au canada où quelque
chose de même j'ai pas il n'y avait pas
eu de l'annnonce du lancet jusque-là
algorithmes en une journée rendue virale
quelque chose mais c'est surtout
regarder les recherches associera 5
juste est pas jcc affecter les
recherches des 5 g coville 5g carnot
virus tripes et on savait qu'il y avait
une association que ces cris ces causes
est tantôt il ya des gens avec des
craintes tout à fait légitime sur sur la
pandémie qui sont partis à la recherche
d'informations parce qu'il savait pas
trop quoi croire puisqu'ils sont aussi
exposés du contenu en lien avec la saint
jean puis les gens de ces les réseaux
sociaux qui a créé cette connexion le
dirigeant c'est sa facilité l'accès à ce
contenu tu vois cette recherche le
google des prélèvements faits moussy
pour essayer de comprendre c'est quoi
les arguments au steak oil et qui toute
la faune ce nouvel toutes les
informations qui autour de tout ce qui
fait que j'ai aussi toutes les
recherches s'étaient déjà ses sacro
complètement mais c'est quand même tu
vas lire c'est peut-être avoir des gens
qui vont les crimes ce que vous ayez un
petit doute le nom c'est sûr qu'avec des
gens qui justement se poser des
questions des juges face à savigny
douceur mais ça montre que ça crée un
véritable phénomène de société métissée
personnes
personne ou presque avant le 15 mars
pour une question c'est bon parce que la
5g cause des symptômes qui ont de leur
de la grippe
donc même si ce n'est même pas dans le
champ d'entendement d'une possibilité de
réellement c'était donc donc le fait
qu'il apprenait déjà la da qui
recherchait des des arguments pour
contredire leur monocoque un peu quand
même mais juste le fait qu'il ya le
faire qui se pose de questions qui
cherche un prêt à savoir d'où ça vient
ça prouve que cette théorie leur
particulier qui est quelque chose qui
était vraiment marginale de tenir les
théories 5 g ca atteint 3 absolument
immense dont on a vu des vidéos sur
youtube avec c'était des centaines de
milliers
toi tu as entendu parler il ya des gens
qui ont mis dix feux des tours de 5 g
plus bas juste ici en angleterre aussi
sait vraiment si c'est une idée qui sait
comme mise à propager sur les réseaux
sociaux
inquiet vers une association place en
egypte le claviériste jacques on prend
toujours programmée est ce que dans une
situation comme fou dans un climat
politique actuel où est ce que la
personne la plus puissante au monde fait
appel au fait que nos esprits répète
sans arrêt que les médias doivent poète
doivent pas être écoutés et piquez les
nouvelles sont pas légitimes
est-ce que ça va contribuer à cet effet
de cette mouvance le vert vers les
théories plus alternatives bonne
question je pense que la question de la
polypill of de contredire les médias
puis d'aller chercher un certain pouvoir
contredisant les médias faut qu'il y ait
une certaine méfiance le soit pas dans
une population qui fait ce soir
confiance aux médias fait le plus
confiance
il renaît recrutement de ce côté là il
ya tellement de raisons il ya aucune
façon 5 d'expliquer cet éboulis le web
est là dedans
les réseaux sociaux ils sont pour
quelque chose la façon de faire des
médias aussi le cycle des nouvelles des
vingt-quatre heures à la seconde près
sur twitter c'est sûr que ça y est pour
quelque chose des journées de travail
plus vite des plus d'erreurs des choses
comme ça les baisses de budget dans les
journaux qui fait qu'il ya moins de
journalistes pour faire le même travail
que c est ce que en cause et l'autre
c'est plus d'interactions entre deux
facteurs le reste que c'est une source
une source de pouvoir pour certaines
personnes la poche des gens qui ont
complètement abandonné les médias
traditionnels puis pas juste les médias
mais toutes les institutions l'été font
plus confiance aux scientifiques font
plus confiance au gouvernement font plus
confiance au système de santé font plus
confiance aux banques ces gens la
trouvent des solutions de rechange sur
le web pi sacré un indice croire que tu
peux aller chercher c'est quand même un
peu comme une ressource à exploiter pour
certaines personnes c'est un package en
tête on 30% de la population qui est
vraiment mécontent il ya un axe droit
les chercher il ya du pouvoir aller
chercher il ya de larges allées chercher
là dedans donc malheureusement y en a
qui jouent uniquement là dessus on était
pour parler du présent de saint denis en
dessous du pic et l'oeil
il fait tout pour continuer d'alimenter
ce clivage la cgt le terme fille news a
été pratiquement inventé le copyright et
donald trump
c'est drôle parce que la personne qui a
popularisé le temps est venu maintenant
il dit arabe au speed 1 un des parrains
de
l'étude journalistique du phénomène des
forces nouvelles le premier article que
j'ai fait cette course d'une verge et
par la creg
c'est en fait c'est lui qui met
quasiment donné l'idée de face à blake 6
c'est à cause en grande partie à cause
de lui qu'on à l'expression fait news
puis levé quand ça c'était en 2006 juste
avant l'élection c'est quelques semaines
avant l'élection il veut sortir la
première grosse histoire sur regarder
les publications qui fonctionnent le
plus sur facebook le bain les dans le
top 10 en 1 5 qui viennent du et qui
viennent de l'europe de l'est qui ce qui
vient du kosovo où est-ce que tu viennes
la macédoine dans un petit village
s'appelle veulent s en macédoine des
histoires complètement inventé fait que
c'est lui qui comme s'ils savaient une
définition très précise des histoires
inventées qu'ont publié sur les réseaux
sociaux pour aller chercher des cliques
départager testait une exploitation de
la crise humaine ça a été beaucoup
utilisé pour critiquer la victoire du
prise d'un autre homme sont attribués
souvent ceux aux forces nouvelles je
pense que c'est un peu exagéré de dire
que les forces nouvelles ont porté dans
notre choix c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment une vision très simpliste de la
chose comme ça mais finalement qui
encore aujourd'hui mais ça a été
détourné et s'est lui-même s'est
réapproprié expression pour critiquer
des médias se sont établies t exactement
moi ce qui me fait incroyablement bas
justement utiliser steam 30 la
population qui est qu'ils croient plus
aucune institution sur la science les
gouvernements les médias tous ceux qui
citent encore minoritaire c'est me
suffit que le mouvement dans tellement
de popularité tellement de membres tous
les réseaux sociaux que 6ème année il ya
un renversement l'ossétie tout fout
l'camp nautique à t-il la démocratie
public vraiment existe à cause qu'on
décide d'un communément d'y croiser
messier majorité des gens qui croient
puisque 15% des gens croient que le
gouvernement corrompu crois que ben
tout ça forme tout le système dans
lequel on vit sa forme mais c'est s'est
affaissé je ne peux pas faire paniquer
les gens sans dire que c'est la
constance c'est ça l'essence d'une
révolution c'est quand des gens ne
cessent de faire confiance aux
institutions qui décide que ben on
pourrait les remplacer quelque chose qui
fonctionne
je sais pas je sais pas ce que ça
s'envoie très franchement métier le web
puis l'architecturé réseaux sociaux fait
en sorte que les gens ne sont pas
contents des institutions peuvent
développer pour trouver des solutions de
rechange sur le fait que c'est par
exemple les gens font plus confiance aux
banques
bon ben c'est il s'investit dans huit
communes ces choses demain font plus
confiance au système de santé
bon ben on va trouver des médecines
alternatives on va consulter des déchets
youtube qui nous racontent tour de
médicaments d'une confiance aux médias
ben c'est pas grave parce que n'importe
qui peut partir un blog aujourd'hui puis
avec un peu de sous afin que de nos
jours surtout sa tante en demis et même
plus des publications qui sort
l'information souvent cédé des gens des
gens très régulier crime sur le status
facebook ma cousine a connu une
infirmière qui dit que tout est tapissée
par tranche d'âge les milliers des
milliers de la prise effective si
c'était un peu débuts du web c'est à la
démocratisation extrême de la liberté
d'expression extrême que tout le monde a
accès également à l'information il faut
pas juste les universitaires qui ont
accès à l'information ou qu'ils
contrôlent l'information calibre médias
non plus le contrôle sur l'information
que tout le monde a le droit d'avoir
accès à l'information puis de connecter
des gens semblent qui ont des objectifs
communs c'était seul le but du web
fondamentalement certain sens c'est
réussi mais je pense que les
conséquences négatives ont peut-être pas
été on pas été anticipée puis maintenant
on vit avec les conséquences de cela le
web qui à la base était conçu comme un
phare web puisque c'est eux qui s était
vu comme une bonne chose ça a été une
bonne chose pour plein temps plein soit
rentré ongles
mais en même temps ça permet à des gens
de s'organiser pour faire des choses qui
sont pas tout à fait à mon sens bonne ma
vie puis c'est les théories du complot
je rappelle le début 2010 le tien tu
pouvais trouver un vidéo sur youtube qui
parlait devant les pyramides auraient
été faits par des extraterrestres tout
est dit des trucs qui avait pas
d'incident sur notre vie présentement
tic que les extraterrestres fait les
pires à noël parce qu'il y avait trouvé
des objets ont été repêchés pour les
égyptiens ont fait un peu chier pour les
milliers en fait les dizaines de
milliers d'esclaves vraiment pour les
sur ces chiens pour aux autres métiers
ça pas d'incidence sur nous en ce moment
tiers alors que les théories du complot
actuelle pis surtout lié à la queue vite
si je disais sur le site des décrypteurs
si le l'arctique qui regroupait toutes
les théories du complot par rapport à la
coved et puis faut que je coure
longtemps en tabarnak pour te rendre
jusqu'en bol parce qu'on en a fait une
sainte
je voyais passer plus de gens voyant que
je faisais à quai c'est le jeu lévy
passé c'est du passé je lève pas
celle-là je les fais passer peu à peu
près 75 % de toutes les théories qui
sont là j'ai vu passer sur mon fils
d'actualités par des proches par de
nombreux partagent sa part des amis
éloignés pape puis pis ces théories
l'heure on est loin des pyramides
d'egypte maintenant on est dans le
quotidien n'ont ni dans des today on est
dans la pandémie qui nous arrive en ce
moment ça c'est ultra inquiétant c'est
tout un faisan rappel le jeu peut
peut-être vous êtes un peu trop jeune
pour ça mais le film avec mel gibson
gibson je bois conspirationnistes
village a été convaincu que l' acia et
la contrôler plein appui pneumatiques
rencontre mais mes titres un peu les
stéréotypes conspirationnistes jusqu'à
très récemment installé le doute dans
son sous sol qui à celle des cadets des
documents qui dans l'aude et d'un site
web la syrie où quelque chose
qu'est-ce qui fait des connexions des
choses qui n'ont pas nécessairement de
connexion c'est un peu ça les
stéréotypes puis cette pandémie le fait
mentir tous des gens tout à fait
ordinaire puis une chose que je constate
j'ai pas de données scientifiques pour
appuyer ce qu'est ce que je vous disais
qu'on le constate que j'essaie quand
même ce constat informé parce qu'on a
reçu au bob mould je pense
quatre ou cinq mille courriels pendant
la pandémie si on voit qu'ils nous
envoient les courriels puis on voit les
gens de gens qui partagent les réseaux
sociaux le plus gros l'appliance
croissance dans les théories de
conspiration en tout cas en lien avec la
cave de 19,6 et les femmes libres de
faire ming déjà qu est le steack au
titre qu'on a des conspirationnistes
c'est souvent pauvre madame avec trois
enfants qui fait les chroniques de
guidance
mais il ya une ex une très grosse
croissance dans cette population le
pilon lensois des messages de madame qui
sont compensées à vos enfants vous
mentez à la population sait déjà et qui
est hic c'est que ce dommage pour leurs
enfants pour leur famille s'inquiétait
de ses enfants c'est la fin la plus
humaine
dix sept personnes deux malheureusement
sont tombés dans des spirales des
informations consulter l'information qui
est pas bonne puissamment ce prix là
dedans pis ce qui est plate et que tu
vois que ça legear eu vraiment le tri
ces gens-là pense que tout ce qu'on vit
en ce moment le chamboulement des vies
tout le monde l'économie qui pète 7 et
orchestré me semble que quand tu vis
avec ce jour après jour sa ville
chercher témoins moi je peux juste
consulter du contenu comme ça parce qu
ils y croient vraiment sérieusement ça
doit pas les biens 44,3 ces choses non
association tel film avec mel gibson
mais si ces mêmes principes que la
matrix le traitement de tous les gens
qui se rendent pas compte qu'ils vivent
une illusion vettel et quelques
personnes qui ont accès à un autre
niveau tipi ou c'est comme l'allégorie
de la caverne
c'est drôle parce que justement c'est
comme si ces gens le croient qu'ils sont
sortis de la caverne chili voix et la
vérité sont juste plus profond alors que
tout le monde s'y met c'est vraiment
difficile londres est de reconnaître
c'est dans quel sens était têtu un
éveillé ou t on encore plus dans
charlotte éclairer les populations c'est
vraiment intéressant qu'est ce qui ne va
pas c'est que c'est quelque chose que je
constate le mouvement conspirationnistes
en ce moment est vraiment influencé par
la culture des années 90 mais le film
jeff keay sapin c'est hélas vous êtes
des choses qui sont dressés cela dit si
on avait fait un peu de casse avec et
levier bernard l'information pour
longtemps petit monde commente vous fait
aussi partie du complot vous êtes à la
solde du gouvernement jean c'est comme
si tout le monde est pays par le
gouvernement sauve rigueur si on
[Rires]
honnêtement c'est vraiment une
observation qui est très importante
enfants pauvres il parce que quand tu
comprends ces éléments de la culture
populaire des années 90 comprendre
conspirationnistes actuelle l'expert
aussi les années 90 à populariser des
théories du complot comme ça se peut pas
jeter un gros fan des expériences de
problème avec ça même imaginer des liens
en titre a dicté sa [ __ ] et les
l'imagerie des métriques son voile haute
et dans la maîtrise de l'énergie en son
genre
quand quelqu'un essaye de se déployer de
la matrice les agents viennent qui tire
une balle en main intelligent comme
l'impression que c'est ce que moi je
suis là je te jeter un agent qui fait
juste propager la matrice dans l'est
dans laquelle je suis moche le dos pour
facilit trop d'armes
mais pour m
raed salah salaires fou de dire c'est
qu'un film peut avoir autant d'influencé
lemay la culture populaire c'est ça
change énormément la mentalité des gens
on sait tous que ce soient des films des
romans ou des bd mais ça affecte la
façon dont voit le monde
c'est pour ça que les denisovans
artistique c'est toutes les heures entre
6 et savent souvent un gros impact sur
toutes ses formes
quant à eux quand le film par exemple
morizet ce live est sorti du monde qui
ont fait des faits historiques la
culture populaire souvent ça va
atteindre les gens plus que des
documentaires ou cdd les visiteurs et
coudes et malheureusement des recherches
historiques ou des choses que vous quand
il voit dans un contexte dans le film
celui les chercher emotionnellement les
maçons c'est très fort la façon dont on
voit le monde c'est le la base de
watchmen ou est-ce que l'objectif
principal du gosse et d'anéantir une
partie de la population il y avait dans
les théories sur laquelle vit le fait
que bill gates avait créé la coved pour
réduire la population est contraint de
se placer c'est un super méchant le
métier les méchas dans watchmen
il crée une crise mais pour que la page
sur une jeunesse ensemble ça a eu
l'effet contraire c'est comme est-ce que
son plein en asie mendy vraiment
fonctionné je pense qu'il faudrait qu'on
s'immisce pas pour nous très conseillé
unis pendant 15 minutes l'eau des bulles
est quand même un mouvement tel
d'actrice et on s'y tient puis vraiment
moment qui a eu la plus grande cassure
sylla masque de quelqu'un qui a causé le
port du masque à l'intérieur puis je
comprends même pas pourquoi c'est ce que
fait briser les respecter parce que
c'est pour la mesure la plus de la
grogne est montée depuis le confinement
t'es juste le fait de
dès qu'on finit presque totalement ses
premiers plus extrêmes qui est
maintenant qu'un trouver dans quelque
part à l'intérieur tu mets ton masque
c'est ce qui était commun ont été la
goutte d'eau qui a débordé en bonne
question c'est vrai en fixer soi qui a
donné lieu à des manifestations goût
est ce que c'est parce que ben c'est
arrivé justement après deux ou trois
mois de confinement que les gens étaient
déjà guéri d'être confiné plus on vient
leur acheter ça est ce que je sais en
revanche parce que c'est quelque chose
de physique tu es resté chez histoire
c'est peut-être moins intéressant que m
vraiment quelque chose sur le visage
c'est quelque chose que bien des gens
aiment pas c'est incompréhensible ce
soir m'en parle souvent d'une prime à
défaut tout en étant charron conduit
pour venir faire un podcast
tiens on prend des mesures sanitaires
c'est aussi dû au dessus et puis on met
nos marques
je me sens pas du tout restreint de quoi
que ce soit dans ma liberté
on peut on peut aller prendre un verre
dans un mort je mets ton match nul en
dévastatrice et comme c'est tellement
pauvre c'est vraiment pas grave
l'argument c'est on veut museler la
population d'ananas je me sens pas
museler le moindrement le comprend
maintenant quelqu'un qui devrait
travailler que son masque le 8 heures
par jour je comprends si ces plates même
si des dates très désagréable en fin de
semaine en état avec un chirurgien qui
était sur notre équipe d'universitaires
les gueux il fait des opérations qui
dure des dizaines d'heures bien sûr
c'est un peu qu'est ce qu'ils veulent et
peuvent unir pour degrés est et je peux
comprendre que les gens se remettent en
question le virus tue les gens peuvent
pas examiné un virus rue main on ne pas
dire en microbiologie à la maison faute
des années d'étude pour comprendre
l'amitié
les gens partent un deuxième report on
peut pas le voir de se dire les
symptômes 7 spots en jack se disant bien
on peut pas aller contre nous-mêmes
chacun des décès faut qu'on se fie aux
statistiques venant prendre quelque part
on doit s'en remettre à des autorités
qui ne serait pas conforme à ses
attentes et l'ofppt tu fais pas
confiance aux informations qui en
proviennent mais le maersk c'est quelque
chose que tu peux observer toi même
vous avez vous tout est allé au japon
tout le monde en porte les transports en
commun justement les chirurgiens portes
pendant des heures les dentistes les
menuisiers plein de monde pour des
masques à chaque jour maintenant ce
moment là ça fait quoi un mois et demi
qui est le monde portent des masques
quand ils sortent de chez eux est-ce
qu'on a une grosse vague de gens qui
sont décédés à cause des manants saison
espèrent constater toi même c'est pas
dangereux porter nas puis quand même et
on recommence en question c'est vraiment
si on est vraiment dans l'univers
parallèle
donc c'est ceux qui kiffent ricard plus
avec cet exemple penly c'est quelque
chose que tu peux observer tout pour
revenir juste un petit peu à quelque
chose qu'on avait dit un petit peu plus
tôt une en conversation j'ai vu un tweet
genre tu sais qu'il a partagée qui
disait que dans le fond en ce moment on
assiste à la science ce que tu disais
tout à l'heure que des scientifiques
allemands en avant un consensus sur un
virus ils font plusieurs plusieurs
plusieurs études puis nous ce qu'on soit
à la fin de tout ça c'est le résultat de
la démarche scientifique
mais la démarche scientifique si remplie
de deux poids d'avant pour un pas de
recul pour un tir de décès erreur de
choses que tu apprends puis quitta
millions la technique puis j'ai
l'impression que le remettons le monde
entend vlo quatre mois le docteur arruda
des règles le masque c'est pas
nécessairement sur la priorité
actuellement plus la pression quatre
moteurs de dialogue tout le monde ont
fortement parce que comme comme fin du
raid de big lebowski new chitose come to
drive on a appris des nouvelles affaires
dans la démarche scientifique qui nous
amène à dire ce fait on est en train
d'assister à la science mais j'ai pas
l'impression aussi tout le monde qui
prêt à accepter que c'est sur la science
c'est tout le temps le danger puis ça
c'est quelque chose de leurs rapports
troubles entre l'actualité placions
c'est quelque chose qui me préoccupe
depuis longtemps les médias font une
mauvaise jobs est là c'est en général
parce qu'on très petit jeu blanc
personne mais on traite la science comme
c'est un sujet d'actualité donc une
nouvelle étude dit que le chocolat noir
fait perdre du poids
lalande
une nouvelle étude du cash à grenon
finalement ça fait pas peur de poppy le
constat pour la personne normale c'est
ben ne savent pas de quoi ils parlent
comme le dit la science est un processus
qui des x men à des maladies cul-de-sac
des fois il ya des choses et d'une vaste
étude qui contredit sur le devant c'est
un processus continu
c'est ici ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
te définitif le jour même
c'est exactement ce citoyen 1 étude
c'est une vaste étude scientifique en
temps réel loin on est tous des sujets
de laboratoire d'une étude non seulement
de virologie mais d'épidémie allergies
comme de faire des prises il ya des
prévisions des prédictions qui ce sport
il ya des mesures de santé publique
peut-être que c'était pas la bonne chose
à faire
un pit il les maisons de santé publique
ont été critiqués par des scientifiques
pour des épidémiologistes du monde dès
le début qu'ils disaient porter des
masques
suite écoutez c'est le problème qui ce
qui est désolant là dedans c'est que
l'image qui en ressort pour beaucoup de
gens c'est que bunge ces gens le savent
policière quoi qu'est-ce qu'ils font ça
parce que qui porte alors qu'on en sait
plus sur le vg ce look il ya quatre mois
un exact mais ce sont des infos des
quatre mots comme argument contre
argument est ce qu'il dit aujourd'hui ce
serait pas de sens puis juste là
tourneur que tu as utilisé en la hante
l'entendant dire à voix haute ça me fait
réaliser comment certaines personnes
peuvent se sentir pris ou prises dans
cette histoire là quand tu as dit on est
tous des sujets vivants d'une étude
scientifique
ongoing aussi fait que le moindrement
qui est étonnant que tout je sais pas
comment qualifier ça
troubles de faiblesse mais ton mental
outils dans ta personnalité puis que le
tout sans prix dans ce qu'on parle
depuis tantôt c'est la matrice un espèce
de sentiment que ton rôle de laboratoire
que là ils veulent te contrôler pour été
pour mettre des micros peut souhaiter
aux bulles la raison si au final les
problèmes que ça contribue aussi à
sentir c'est moi j'ai pour devrient g
j'ai de l'empathie pour les gens qui
tombent là dedans c'est pas de leur
faute
il y avait des gens qui ont des craintes
tout à fait légitime
le problème c'est qu'ils sont allés
chercher des mauvaises sources
d'information qui sont tombés là dedans
mais c'est pas de leur faute du poids
qui sont pas intelligents c'est pas du
tout j'aime pas trop ça il ya plein
mouvement de backlash condé
conspirationnistes en ce moment sociaux
puis on les traite d'idiot puis de deux
caves et c'est vraiment productif parce
que quand il ya quelqu'un qui est
caviste un idiot vapoter coûté ils
lisent encore plus les médias qui ont
besoin une conversation mais c'est sa
vigne de sa vie de quelque chose de
sincère p'tit quinquin les gens
partagent la désinformation c'est qui
exprime quelque chose quand on partage
d'informations sur les réseaux sociaux
ce pop pour informer nos amis ce pour
montrer notre point de vue sur le monde
des réseaux sociaux ça sert à créer une
autre identité sur le web
quand je partage un article du devoir ou
de journal de montréal je le partage pas
ce que ça dit quelque chose sur moi
plutôt que sur la société créée ce
partage un quiz qui dit qu'il a de lui
est ce que c'est certain que moi je suis
vraiment plus banal mais c'est une
métisse et puis quand je pense qu'il
faut écouter les gens plutôt que de tout
cas d'écouter leurs discours qui dit on
est pris dans la matrice écoute le liant
tellines ce texte c gepa j'ai vraiment
pensé par des enfants peut-être que j'ai
perdu ma job peut-être que mon couple
s'est détruit parce que le stress de
l'aco vie depuis le confinement avec les
enfants ça au petit tellement chose là
dedans lockheed nous tout ce qu'on voit
c'est le produit final la personne qui
partage la conspiration quelques mais ça
vient de quelque part qui qui qui est
authentique c'est vraiment il ya des
inquiétudes l'adapter je parle à des
folkloristes l'année dernière dans le
corps de l'autre
puis les folkloristes les forces
nouvelles sont comme moi ce qui
expliquait c'est le folklore les autres
constats les forces nouvelles comme une
forme de folklore c'est pas précis pour
ce qui se passe actuellement dans la
société mais c'est ultra précis pour
savoir les peurs société les inquiétudes
les éléments folkloriques souvent se dit
monstre mais c'est en référence à des
stress que les gens vis tu regardes de
le folklore dans le temps par exemple
dans l'empiré romain il disait que les
chrétiens buvait le sang des enfants
suivent pourquoi ben c'est pas ce que
dit être déstabilisé par cette nouvelle
religion le qui venait de débarquer dans
l'empiré romain puis sentais que ça
allait peut-être changer la composition
de leur société puis la meilleure
manière d'exprimer leur part des
footballeurs santé oui
l'affirmation tant que telle elle est
pauvre et mes skis sous jacentes
ça parle vraiment pour vous quand tu
regardes les conspirations qui sont
déployés par rapport à la cave 19 que la
pandémie est bien certain de vérité en
ti de sauce qui les gens expriment leur
inquiétude très très profonde qu'est ce
qui se passe et c'est en même temps tu
peux pas en vouloir et des conspirations
des vrais conspiration il y en a eu le
watergate une conspiration le cpie des
lits gouvernement puis des médias suite
en allemagne nazie les légendes et
brunoy celle par la propagande pcc des
choses sont déjà arrivés dans l'histoire
est-ce que c'est impossible que ça
arrive non lic et des gens qui sont
ultra aux aguets par rapport à ce qu'ils
voyaient même quinquis et paul koch dans
le monde entier mais justement typique
des quoi faire avec ces personnes-là
leur entourage ses mots j'étais coupable
de des abonnés de dirigeants de quinon
ces personnes je l'enlève de ma liste
d'amis piment de décommander entre une
publication a été été dans chance et
puis c'est clairement pas la bonne chose
à faire parce que premièrement commenté
en dessous ça va juste c'est plus une
tentative d' humilier une personne qui
est vraiment laissé de l'argent et des
savoirs un dialogue écrit l'un privé
très bas toi tu as fait
et puis après c'est justement c'est
clairement des gens qui sont victimes
d'isolement qui souffre d'isolement
c'est donc après ce si tout était la
seule personne dans son facebook qui
partageait pas ce genre d'idée le
pétulant la liste d'amis irrécupérable
bien encore parce que ces gens la
plupart des gens ne sont pas conscients
pourcentage la minorité on le voit
beaucoup parce que ces gens l'ont écrit
m parce que mettons que questionne le
port du masque que tu penses que il a eu
le temps de bruno sang d'enfant pour
dénoncer c'est pas du tout les mêmes
mais mais mais c'est un bon point car
quand x 6 2 pour les ailiers encore plus
parce que tu es ces gens le soin vont
poster quelque chose d'un peu oui sur
leur page facebook sont visés par tout
le monde et seront différents départs
mains des gens ben le message qui
ressort c'est où je trouverais et me met
les gens dans mon groupe facebook
conspirationnistes mes vrais amis
qu'est ce que personne faire s'enfonce
encore plus la même fecteau c'est sûr
qu'il écrit des commentaires en
publications celles soit les gens vont
se braquer parce qu'ils sont comme
exposé en public ils veulent pas perdre
la face du monde d'être des messages
privés c'est peut-être plus productifs
puis de ne pas accuser non plus parce
que quand accuse quelqu'un s'éteignirent
ce que tu as partagé c'est complètement
stupide
on va pas tu écoutais correct et c'est
un chose nous on se fait dire ce que je
participais pas mal des décors et al
jadid jeunes de son pourrissement dire à
tout le monde est-ce que j'ai le goût
d'écouter leurs deux arguments quand je
me fais parler comme ça enfin pitié
mettons qu'on qu'on essaie de voir on
parlera plus en détail tout à l'heure
des groupes conspirationnistes plus
précis mais si on sait la peur c'est la
porte centrale c'est qu'ils ont conçu
fait contrôler mais dont le gouvernement
ne contrôle
quelle est la solution parce que
admettons qu'on essaie de penser une
solution à moyen long terme pour les
réseaux sociaux d'essayer de contrôler
les mieux possible les groupes était de
faire vraiment une coupure claire en
pièces que une instance de
légitimisation juge comme étant
nécessaire ou du moins pas mauvaise
qu'est-ce qu'on juste comme étant des
grilles du complot des trucs qui vont
marcher les gens parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'en faisant ce tu donnes
un petit peu raison à l'idée qu'on se
fait contrôler team fait que tu en
prenant la décision de vouloir les
utiliser ou non certains groupes
certaines idées certaines on dirait que
tu donnes un peu raison à l'idée
contrôler les pensées c'est que c'est
vraiment pas évident j'avais la
grossesse c'est qu'il ya quand même pas
de réponse on dirait parce que titre ces
choses là tu te dis fessée c'est pas
évident par contre pour certains cas
extrêmes ça peut fonctionner par exemple
il y avait le fameux documentaire
pandémique double kaki sortir quelques
semaines le premier avait fait été vu le
10 millions de fois en 24 heures
facebook a décidé de le supprimer avant
même que le documentaire est fini des
diffusé donc moi je l'écouté en direct
la première la première diffusion et en
dirait que d'écouter un qui déjà après
trente quarante minutes donc on va quand
même du nord et 20 tu peut plus partager
le ding sur facebook un quinqua levé le
flag ont pris une décision ça mais ça
fonctionne et une finale en 2002 tahin
nul parle
ouais on n'a pas vu l'engagement que sa
société le premier c'est un documentaire
est encore plus long peut-être parce que
documentaires des poches aussi fille est
vraiment là tu le mets peut-être c'est
partager dans des groupes
marginalisée sauf que sur facebook à
grande écoute du tout le monde peut
toujours trouver des malades et le
partage de changer les choses comme ça
mais marge ac c'est plus c'est pas du
tout ça existe mais ce pas youtube ya
quand même un danger leur à savoir que
facebook une entreprise californienne
peuvent contrôler l'elysée ces caisses
qui juge les autres fosses à l activité
l'a t mais oui mais c'était
l'objectivité de caisse qui dit ferri
fiable après ce c'est ça ça marche super
bien qu'un que l'entreprise on juge qui
est bienveillante qui affaiblissent
travail lot de départager le vrai du
faux puis livrée nouvelles des fausses
nouvelles
sauf que si tu penses que cette
entreprise le un agent 2 qui veut
promouvoir cette idée plus que d'autres
se met le savent bien que c'est simon
problématique si c'était le cas ça
serait très problématique c'est parce
que société on a aucun mot facebook
jean kandé kanté membres de facebook
quand un compte facebook dit d'accord
avec les conditions d'utilisation pilati
genre tout petit peut pas aller contre
les règles d'utilisation
c'est solide c'est ça la loi puis en
tant que utilisateurs de facebook on
peut pas non plus voté sur qui le dit
jean facebook on peut pas voter sur des
propositions à québec en tant que
communauté ont décelé une sauce ont vu
plus haut sur notre plateforme sont
reçus non ça c'est une compagnie privée
dans cuisine copains qui se retrouvent
avec un pouvoir énorme qui se met au
même niveau qu un gouvernement mondial
mais qui géré par des gens qu'elle
fournit ses disques ou pis c'est ça on
n'a pas notre mot à dire c'est ça c'est
ça le problème fondamental l'été quand
le gouvernement met en place certaines
lois qui contreviennent d'expression je
pense par exemple aux discours haineux
mais au moins sur papier on n'est pas
content avec ça on peut voter changer le
banc même à changer la loi
ted techniquement c'était beaucoup plus
compliqué que cela mais l'option aller
le mais quand facebook dit ben on bannit
telle la fin j'ai pas mon mot à dire non
plus dompter d'y être quand même
inquiétant surtout qu'elle entend de
l'humanité sur facebook mais c'est ce
htc
ces deux points quelques milliards
l'enfance et plus que n'importe quel
était finalement
puis leur équipe de sécurité à peu près
autant d'employés que la ville de
montréal qui était en pointe quelques
millions de personnes ces gens là
doivent surveiller tout le facebook d'un
million des systèmes d'automatisation
qui détecte la plupart des faux contrats
voire même sont mis en ligne il détecte
du contenu à une heure avant même
qu'elle soit publiée par keefe a reste
que cette entreprise-là énormément de
responsabilités là c'est comme si tu as
wihr le pays de 2.6 milliards de
personnes ne se coincent à nantua
mettant la bonne manière que facebook
pourrait gérer ces pratiques sont
quasiment rendu à un point qui peuvent
plus sont rendues elles sont tellement
gros
en ce moment c'est pas seulement 2.6
milliards de personnes 2.3 millions de
personnes qui publient sur facebook mais
c'est aussi un combien de langues
combien de dialectes régionaux t c'est
écrit un message annulant québécois est
ce que quelqu'un qui vérifie les
commentaires qui vient de france veulent
comprendre la plus haute des messages et
nos québécois sont aussi très fait
syntaxe mais se retrouve méga entreprise
qui doit gérer les communications de
milliards de gens des dizaines des
centaines de milliers de millions de
messages par jour sont rendus à un point
où ils peuvent sont comme passé la jeune
on voté moi ça me fascine parce que ces
réseaux sociaux la base c'était pas des
entreprises s'étaient pas de plateforme
pour des échanges d'informations mais
facebook c'est un site de rencontres
pour universal le savant s'il a fait
envoyer quelqu'un exact heures twitter
c'est un site de microbloguage pour les
podcasteurs pour juste mettre à jour
d'ios pour ça que c'est petit si tout
est ok pour dire écoute on est certes un
nouveau podcast cliquez ici instagram
c'est une application pour les amateurs
de whisky ses célèbres urbaine
on était pour poster des photos jean
ringer butelle bourbon à telle place ou
le soir du whisky c'est donc à la base
des seuils ont fait le choix quelque
part d'étendre leurs activités puis
d'englober la planète au complet les se
retrouve à peu être capable de gérer ce
qui ce passe en pâtissent
je pas très sympathique en valeur des
cds choix conscients qu'ils ont été
faites dans ces entreprises là de dire
ok ben on devient quelque chose d'autre
on va chercher le maximum d'abonnés
possible là il se retrouve sont plus
capables de jerry 2.4 millions d'abonnés
mais c'est eux qui sont allés les
chercher le point 4 milliards d'abonnés
y aurait pu dire ben non nous on regarde
le modèle que c'est juste des
universitaires qui peuvent aller sur
facebook que pour te proposer à facebook
faut qu'il dise quelle université
t'appartient tout heureux ce rapport
n'était plus gérable
donc c'est des conséquences inattendues
de choix qui ont été faits dans le losc
retrouve c'est ça devient ingérable
les mettons en date d'aujourd'hui le but
partager un article d'un blog d'extrême
droite qui dit qui est justement au bas
mot des esclaves dans son sous sol et
ont créé un poste qui était dans le
texte empreint pas les règles
d'utilisation fait que tous suspendus
discours haineux si tu n'es pas de mot
raciste ou quelque chose de même
surprendre et que ton pour acheter des
publicités l'époque une chose mettez
mettons tous les articles de blog
douteux ou de thomas de magazines
d'extrême droite ou gauche peu importe
le train parce que six qui s'exporte âge
carrément td fausse nouvelle s'écrient
toutes pièces pour attirer déclic
si ce serait me semble assez facile à
détecter était déjà de publications
virale qui se portait normalement comme
ce matin lyon il faudrait l'oeil
facebook ont mis beaucoup beaucoup des
fortes et je reposte taper sur facebook
n'ont pu y ont mis beaucoup beaucoup
d'efforts depuis on est passé des
examens qui dit que c'est complètement
fou de penser que les forces nouvelles
peuvent avoir un effet sur la politique
est aujourd'hui qu'il ya des politiques
envers la désinformation sont en
évolution constante
on est à des années lumière de ce que
c'était il ya quatre ans certains sites
qui sont blacklistés sur facebook peut
pas partager des lignes de ce site et
les éléments les plus extrêmes sont dans
cette black list l'hôte et donc je pense
pas que je pourrai aller sur facebook
les gens le plus gros site néo nazis
mais c'est vraiment celle elling saison
grise qui sont celles où est-ce que ça
devient quelque chose de mieux un
discours remis en liberté a une limite
rentrer un discours qui jugent et pour
certains chacun mais qui est pas une
puis andy cohen ou est ce qu'elle est
cette limite le sait ce qui est
difficile c'est quand ces extrêmes c'est
facile à gérer le tout quelqu'un qui m'a
dit que le low cost jamais eu lieu
c'est super facile à dire regarde on
efface ton poste puis c'est fini
mais l'os ou est ce qu'elle est la ligne
la ligne
c'est ce qui s'est vraiment difficile à
faire des politiques qui sont universels
pitt petit trop prompt justement à
enlever les commentaires le ca devient
justement là c'est ta liberté
d'expression qui briment ça reste une
valeur beaucoup de gens qui brandissent
comme comme comme creux recours à la
voix de kwak je faisais n'importe quoi
un métier n'empêche que c'est une valeur
fondamentale de la société du roi de
tournai pignon sur rue petit déjà eu des
sociétés dans lesquelles tout est une
opinion pis qu'elles ne cherchez-vous
pitof à mi temps voyait jamais ça et
puis on vit dans une société comme ça
mais ça ça existe mais c'est cette cpie
film liberté d'expression facebook
n'existe pas c'est pas des gouvernements
sont aucunement régie par les lois qui
protègent la liberté d'expression
facebook veut retirer ton post ya droit
c'est une compagnie privée
ils n'ont pas besoin de ceux souscrits
roll all one s'est justifié non
absolument pas
l'entreprise privée là est le problème
c'est que nos communications passent
maintenant en grande partie dans des
entreprises comme ceux qui peuvent faire
comme bon leur semble sur ces
plateformes est ce qu'une chose qui unit
je pense que nous ferons sur le web
étrange si ça existe c'est que c'est pas
mal tout le monde est mécontent de la
façon dont les réseaux sociaux gère les
communications d'un côté des dirigeants
qui disent et facebook vous alimenter
les discours haineux les extrémistes
vous faciliter
l'harcèlement des gens sur les réseaux
sociaux l'autre côté côté vous censurer
des discours avec lequel vous n'êtes pas
d'accord
tout le monde est d'accord que facebook
facebook
c'est une des choses qui unit et en
équipement des gens avec des idées des
points de vue complètement opposées sont
les deux sont mécontents de la façon que
les réseaux sociaux j'avais comme
question youtube est quasiment pire le
jeu l'impression ou aussi perdu - parce
que tu regardes un vidéo est un autre
qui parle et une télécommande à sion ça
devient rapidement se dit j'ai pas
l'impression qu' aucun contrôle sur
youtube en ce qu'on fait beaucoup le
ménage cyril et ont fait énormément de
ménages si j'ai pu faire moi même
l'expérience il ya deux ans j'avais fait
une expérience où je mettais j'avais
regardé les recommandations youtube
j'avais écrit je vérifie gentil
gouvernance des mourgues des mots clés
avec la tuerie à québec la mosquée de
québec
j'avais écrit dans gougaud mosquée de
québec tuerie pilote aller chercher
toutes les recommandations pis les
recommandations des recommandations puis
les accommodations des recommandations
des condamnations pu y avait énormément
de contenu sous suite c'est un genre les
champs qui était le plus à commander
c'est à deschamps il y avait clairement
un problème on a fait l'expérience
années passées pendant l'élection
fédérale plus de contenu
conspirationnistes dans les
recommandations qu'elle soit 0 quand tu
écrivais des mots-clés canada parce que
c'est une élection canadienne décrivez
jean justin trudeau le nom des parties
des choses comme ça on avait automatisé
sur un piton est allé chercher des
milliers des milliers de recommandations
avec quasiment vieille ont vraiment fait
le ménage là-dedans l'inversé qu'on eu
l'impression qu'il a commandés juste
pour deux sujets qui ont un lien avec
l'élection de cuisine des vidéos de
make-up des choses comme ça donc youtube
tout cas dire on va je serai commandé du
bon contenu et on se fait remonter
t'intéresses à quelque chose qui
polarise 1
paul tout le monde et c'est le constat
auquel on en est arrivé là il ya eu un
ménage
il ya eu lieu vraiment ménage dans les
rémunérations des tout petits puisque
c'était faut le saluer ces choses là il
ya eu quand même mais quand même ce
ménage dans les réseaux sociaux pour
ouvrir la cia un présent tout va
tellement plus vite que n'importe qui
peut réagir c'est tout les étrennes sont
vraiment plus rapide bits et la paire de
contrôle se fait vraiment plus vite que
le contrôle pur gagner j'ai l'impression
sur toutes ces quatre cantons justement
ben en fait je lisais ton article sur
les théories en fait le groupe yoann qui
était qui et était sur forte gêne mais
après ça c'est pour cannes fait un flop
un autre tweet après plein autres puis
comment tu réagis tout se sait que c'est
impossible c'est comme il y en a tout le
temps c'est vraiment dresse ça se
propage
exactement comme un virus le comme une
épidémie tilly fausses nouvelles pistes
et c'est quasiment secteur même le tai
chi minh hanh c'est carrément une secte
moi l'âme en pis j'ai l'impression 6 à
6,6 transmettre d'un email d'un
ordinateur à un autre
comme un virus ce que je sais des
mutations bon exemple plein d'amis que
j'en parlais tantôt qui revisite potager
de ligne mais les gens sont entre des
façons ils couple et leurs deux fils
partage où il partage en images avec lui
dont ils trouvent des façons ils ne sont
sont intelligents cdc des êtres humains
être humain est vraiment créatif trouver
des façons de communiquer dessus puis
trop des façons de contourner n'importe
quel poste qui est mise en place
ouais c'est ça c'est ça puis le problème
c'est ça aussi c'est que t'es ok on peut
pas contrôler les compagnies privées ils
font ce qu'ils peuvent a guest mais on
peut on peut rien faire non plus du côté
gouvernemental le tir plus on ne peut
plus de recours si à moins qu'il fasse
comme en chine et étudie facebook peut
pas exister ici c'est la pire chose ça
c'est une tranquille sans pitié quand je
remarque que les pays qui ont mis en
place des lois contre les fêtes news
c'est souvent que le gouvernement qui se
mettent à décider qu est ce qui est vrai
ou non il
un danger clair et je me fais souvent
posé la question de ces les mains des
gens qui sont communs qui sera pas de
bon sens pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont poli
forces nouvelles illégal c'est comme non
pas un contexte d'élections où était le
gouvernement décide que le scandale qui
sortent leur journal s'est défait de
news je vais faire un journal fait
emprisonner les journalistes et on on le
voit là la pente est trop bizarre si
cette rumeur est encore ça marche super
bien si le gouvernement était 100%
bienveillant et un objectif mais si
jamais le coude
et puis type les cocons 10e on sonne
quasiment conspirationnistes c'est que
six mois complexe et plus sereine
l'homme y est exact que le communisme
dans un utopie ça fonctionne bien sur tu
rends toi êtres humains dans le tissu
dans l'histoire ça marche
exact mais je vais signer où je serais
allé tantôt en parlant de liberté
d'expression c'est l'impression qui est
le pignon il devenu suprême le plus haut
que le fai tripy tu vois quelqu'un qui
était mettant un exemple des dialogues
qui quand vos dires des plus de garçons
filo l'autre votre brillant non le dans
les faits depuis 2004 puis le bas c'est
mon opinion dire simpliste la liberté
d'expression pinana petit peu comme les
lapins ce qu'est une controverse surtout
et quelques semaines à savoir que deux
places de galles poteau joker pour ger
pauvres ayant recours aux canons des
académiques jandari délivre la tige le
moment je prends bâtiment ce sujet là
mais c'était le compte de 2022
la seule vérité maquiller même et servir
ce que je défends tous et que les
réseaux sociaux c'est une façon de
construire le monde que la façon d'être
que tu vois le monde donc dans ce
contexte de l'opinion c'est important
c'est plutôt que de dire voici les faits
irréfutables c'est voici ma vision du
monde
puis il ya aussi le fait que les réseaux
sociaux je pense beaucoup à facebook et
twitter présent toute pratique d'opinion
puis un article journalistique qui a pas
de différence et dans un journal au
moins c'est que ça continue il est mon
vieux journaux papiers dans une section
tc caen mais lorsque l'information est
organisé et et de la première page qui
l'information le plus important après
sauter les camps l'arctique est plus
petit bain les gens ont raison juge
extrêmement important que l'arctique qui
plus gros peter une section opinion qui
clairement c'est la section opinion les
textes qui sont ici c'est des opinions
mais le camp s'est présenté tout
palmarès ça peut porter à confusion mais
ses potes c'est seul problème c'est que
c'est pas tout les opinions qui sont
équivalentes
si maintenant je prends un exemple
simple mais tu en donnes tu es étudiant
en musique là moi je dis je veux faire
un faty le jeu fait face c'est papa tout
un fan tout va me dire ce point fait
actuellement pas fait moi je vous donne
ma non mais tu pensé points forts moi je
trouve que dans le fond oui clairement
son opinion à toi vaut beaucoup plus que
la mienne et higuain messi tout sur sa
patrie du monde sur ton froc ballon mais
exact cela ça te permet d'aller chercher
un autre tout tellement beau style de
musique ou le fasse et enfin c'est pas
ben ya du monde sur sa part l'embarqué
du monde d'anton dans ton dans ton trip
balayette soir un paquet de monde qui
vont peser banon se pose lui raison de
soucis raison
c'est ça qui peut pas on peut pas
considérer on peut pas considérer toutes
les opinions
pareil mais si tu préfères transpose mes
tantes exemple aux changements
climatiques
factuellement ci ont servi à 6 99% des
scientifiques s'entendent pour dire que
les chiffres démontrent que c'est vrai
se dit que c'est faux si c'est pas juste
une opinion c'est que tu t'opposes à la
vérité après ceux du pavot une opinion
basée sur difc béton qui décide de qui
c'est vrai mais je décide que je
m'accorde ici que nous aussi l'être
humain et disparaître dérange pas de
soucis ton opinion mais exact le fait
est que si réelle juste en face ça
permet ces choses là ça permet à
beaucoup de gens de composer avec des
dimensions qui sont compliqués t je
reprends la pandémie comme exemple temps
de pandémie qui sort de nulle part qui
allume un aucun contrôle sur ce virus là
ça se met à chambouler la vie de tout le
monde
tu peux accepter ce fait loeb c'est pas
cool tu dis pas un crime je suis un
humain très petit je suis à la merci de
la nature même si on est au 21ème siècle
puis on a des ordinateurs dans nos
poches puis qu'on peut prendre l'avion
quand on veut avant la pandémie même été
c'est quand même une réalisation qui est
inconfortable de se dire ma vie est
complètement changé par quelque chose
que je peux pouvoir toucher
tu peux te réconforter en disant ça tout
est inventé c'est ça qui permet de se
remettre de pas être confronté à une
réalité qui est qui et qui est vraiment
inconfortable qui sert une chose pour
changement climatique plutôt que tannis
qui mène dans trente ans la terre vont
être complètement le climat va être
complètement détruit puis mes enfants
vont peut-être vivre dans un monde
pocket post apocalyptique
non plutôt que de dire si vous mentez
même chose pour liszt irrité à chaque
fois qu'une série legend et annonce des
acteurs c'est le dip state qui est mis
dix acteurs pour si je m'entends dessus
par exemple c'est quelque chose qui se
poseraient jockey chaque fois qu'une
tuerie quelconque des gens qui partagent
des séquences vidéo qui disent va
regarder les gars qui est mort on le vit
dans
notre série 2 ans et toutes ses mises en
est pas une souris au monde qui a pas de
mise en scène plutôt que de confronter
le fait que le public aime ça pourrait
arriver à toi ce qui est vraiment pas
cool à septembre y est clairement l
espèce de porc pide d un déni d'un déni
d'un vrai changement en fait le déclin
n'est qu'un bouleversement de quelque
chose il ya vraiment une réaction quand
même façon si je disais tantôt que c'est
les gens qui vivaient des conspirations
c'est très anxiogène mais pour pour
certaines personnes c'est étrangement
réconforte qui dit que quand ça fait
partie d'un plan des gens qui a pas de
postes auxquelles chacun un troc rempli
seuls 2 explose bien il le montre capote
pas parce que tôt ou tard si un autre
bus sont des gens adorent ça fait pas
partie du plan fait que les régions
capote mais il ya un peu un jeu posté
feller c'est que genre ben ça fait
partie d'un plan factice at il été
orchestrée ça rentre dans cette case ça
fait personnages principaux que la vie
et brandon que l'univers d'un homme qui
peut t'arriver des malheurs du jour au
lendemain sur le quai tôt par contre on
serait parti en réalité et y quand les
gens disent si j'ai fait mes recherches
qui je le sais quel masculin la nasa
sera rien au début c'est un peu une
vraie démarche scientifique
tripy ii j'ai une hypothèse puis je veux
faire des expériences pilotes arrivés à
la conclusion selon les données que le
masque ccg nu dgg profondément le masque
me dérangeait pris avec ça puis je vais
aller chercher les informations qui
confirment cette idée le six pouces et
pas impartial comme recherche dcd
recherche qui est des jeux sur internet
puis je trouve
ou est ce que les gens pensent comme moi
je m'accroche là dessus malheureusement
on a parlé tantôt le des fondatrices du
web
conséquence les formats soit accessible
à tous donc toute l'information est
accessible à tous la mauvaise comme la
bonne soit importe quelle est ton
opinion dégâts lundi dans l'attaqué
je peux trouver quelqu'un qui pense
comme toi seulement n'importe quoi
si tu peux y penser il ya quelqu'un qui
a quelque part écrit quelque chose
là-dessus sans pour ça le mentionner le
11 septembre dans tout le 11 septembre
c'était steve c'est la première fois
j'étais confronté à une idée de
conspiration il est même hué le film de
copains fernet nos élèves est qui qui
traitait de ce nom qui ça a été
peut-être que je me trompe peut-être que
c'est juste mon âge qui kim trahi mais
moi ça a été ma première fois où est ce
que j'ai vu vraiment surprendre action
sur une situation actuelle
c'était un homme le tir ça a été ça a
été partagé ça a été moins liste et la
naissance des réseaux sociaux mais
malgré ce c'était une des théories les
plus connus l'utiliser et puis à
l'époque où je me souviens très bien
avoir eu un sérieux doute le temps
décidé le crime est notre affaire même
avoir écouté les veines à l'école ouais
ouais je me rappelle même sort c'est
débile serait quand même un tc lons
septembre certaine conspiration
c'est une vraie conspiration une
plaquette gens qui se sont mis ensemble
pour un plan secret pour faire sauter
l'avion dans l'île pour faire rentrer
des avions dans les bâtiments ça devrait
construire un groupe de personnes c'est
une conspiration qui englobe lions de
personnes mais oui c'est tu as raison tu
es c'était dans les prévenus it de
youtube - le documentaire loose change
et que j'écoutais à l'époque il ya
quelque chose de séducteur la donne en
plus avec le 11 septembre c'est que ça a
été récupérée pour la gare en direct les
gens se sont vraiment senti qu'ils se
sont fait rouler dans la farine puis les
mini médias sont embarqués labège
je me le fais dire ce qu'étaient les
médias bce qui ont permis aux états unis
dans vers l'irak avec la fête new / lit
sur les armes les armes de destruction
massive en irak c'est tout à fait vrai
cela la fois ci c'est les chroniqueurs
de ces journaux le qui sont embarqués la
vda pis la raison pourquoi tu sais qu'il
n'a pas d'armes chimiques qui avait pas
d'armes chimiques 1
en irak c'est en grande partie à cause
des reportages là dessus qui ont-elles
années les gouvernements nature à
affecter ses seins pour la part des
choses en même temps mais si je peux je
peux vraiment comprendre que les gens se
sont sentis trahis à bas les complots
qui ont été démasqués en fait le grand
majorité du temps par les journalistes
bataillent regret tout et outils juste y
mettons les la pédophilie dans l'église
catholique
hun sen est un complot le drift a lancé
ça a été et trouve t étouffé pendant
tellement longtemps que si des
journalistes qui l'ont mis au jour
si je me fais souvent dit quand j'ai
quand quand j'écris beaucoup de cul
hollande par exemple surtout été le
monde le 10 mai ta gueule ça existe
vraiment le trafic d'enfants du quai
expecting existe pas 10 - ips thing
souci que c'est arrivé à cause de miami
est lourde qui est un journal à miami
qui a mis énormément de ressources pour
sortir cette histoire le envers et
contre tout cela dit c'est vraiment
c'est drôle parce que si tu fais jamais
des choses que les gens ont vu dans les
médias comme preuve qu'elle était tout
le temps le fond des choses qu on
s'épaule dépit des conspirations
anguilles mais je dirais il en existe
probablement le type pour pour mais pas
notamment ceux qu'on attendait juste des
décès écrit nationale pete seeger
mais après si ça prend des preuves pour
avancer sur le tout petit peu juste
avant c'est n'importe quoi que tu penses
qui est vrai ou kate a vu vidéos youtube
qui dit qu'il se le tape en cours depuis
solide
la question c'est quand tu crois qu'une
conspiration sais c'est quoi
l'information comprennent présenté qui
me ferait changer d'idée mais si
t'arrives pas à trouver des éléments
c'était plus dans tes dents une croyance
plutôt que dans notés dans un filtre kan
c non falsifiable que j'emprunte porte
l'information qui est présenté sur
réussi à faire rentrer sans la
conspiration mais l'autre c'est plus
quelque chose qui est rationnel
cg j'ai un ami qui dans l'église santa
logique pitt et moi je me suis dit je
veux pas juste comme dire déconfite et
une grosse conversation le des deux
trois heures à josé a glissé de
comprendre mais tir en bout de ligne
dans la conversation année c'était site
apprenait que devil may skavich qui
comme le chef de ce il disait qu'il y
avait des enregistrements du dans les
conversations privées qui disait que
c'était tout et n'importe quoi est fait
que je sois pas le cash permettons kiki
show man le qui abusait d'aider des
enfants wade voulait pas faire j'en
aurai tous des noms n'ont pas été rendus
là il pas grand chose c'est que tu peux
faire meilleur il taira marien pied
d'immeuble et les gens qui ont dit la
même chose pour donald trump le ticket
ce qui trait changer d'idée on est dans
le domaine de la fois plus de passes que
d'autres shows la ccc le cerveau humain
est comme ça nous porte à avoir des
croyants petitement à des croyances que
quand on dit andré le poste peut très
facilement
on a tous des valeurs très profonde puis
c'est une bonne chose qu'on ait des
choses auxquelles on croit que c'est par
exemple croire à ta famille puisqu'elle
son important pic ya rien que quelqu'un
pourrait dire quand on fera par exemple
qui france où quelqu'un se marier qui
ferait en sorte que tu es tu on fera
serait plus proche c'est des bonnes
choses le met en quelque part les fils
se touchent par des jeux pour des choses
qui ont peut-être pas qu'ils sont pas
productives ya deux mondes sont
embarqués là dedans puis ça devient
aussi séducteur le fait d'avoir la
vérité puisqu'elle les autres sont
endormis encore qui fait son apparition
mais ça explique beaucoup le tcc
vraiment
le fait de croire quelque chose puis de
que ce soit impossible de le démentir il
ya quelque chose d'assez du temps la
danse puis c'est pour rester dans la
religion plus la fois le mouvement qu
anne que tu as parlé beaucoup tu es tu
disais dans l'article que l'élu qu il y
avait même du monde qui avait essayé de
scie qui avait carrément déconstruit
tout ce que dit depuis le début c'est
tout ce qui aurait dit puis ça change
pas le normand tome tout ça ralentit
même paul momentum même de prouver que
des affaires complètement fausses qui
ont été avancés qui sont je sois pas
produit ou le contraire s'est produit au
même pas ralenti le momentum d'un truc
qui fait que c'est à quel point est-il
dans un gymnase une dans une fois dans
une croyance aveugle ainsi beaucoup
d'observateurs ont remarqué que ça
ressemble de plus en plus une secte
religieuse
ces mouvements le tir pour aller
chercher loin pour contredire qui où le
quiou drop numéros 1 et 2 les deux
premiers messages de kew qu'ils sont
universellement reconnus comme étant
laissée vrai message de ce supposé
france écrit le disait que la garde
nationale avaient été déployés dans les
grandes villes américaines procès de
terre le soulèvement qui aurait lieu sap
au lieu des 0 à 0 64 kg ou du jeu mais
bien sûr je vais je m'envole genre je
maintiens mes communications sur ford
chan
adios t il revenu juste et c'est pas
vrai il ya les éliminer le traître
twitter dans mon article
ils ont vendu 150 150 affirmation
démentie complètement fausse
en octobre 70 ans d'octobre il va y
avoir des documents qui vont se dévoiler
puis tous les ennemis de 30 étages a été
ça arrive pour chaque fois que ça arrive
pas les gens y croient par aimer c'est
la même chose avec les sectes
apocalyptiques t on a vu souvent des
siècles 10 des 17 milena rial qui disent
ok ben telle date c'est la fin du monde
préparons-nous la fin du monde arrive
pas le dispenserait que les gens
tournent le dos à la sec non il dédouble
deviennent encore plus convaincu que le
secteur raison de la secte tout
simplement repousser la date
mais c'est la même chose avec avec qui
au namm sais qu'il ya des gens qui ont
écrit sur les réseaux sociaux sur
twitter que si elle domine tunes et
cheikh sarr il en reste une blague y
croire et quand même parce que le
message est plus important que le
personnage parce que c'est un message là
du combo ultime contre le mal
ces séducteurs pour relancer c'est
important pour chacun que devant les
choses quand même que c'est démontre que
probablement la personne qui écrit sous
le pseudonyme de cul ou a changé au fil
des heures noires se sachant que c'est
ce qui se sait comme pis cette idée là
cette idée là de révolution puis de
soulèvement du peuple pi2 de révolte
contre le gouvernement établit et comme
est aussi romantiser puis séductrice le
team et on veut ne pas penser à v pour
vendetta ou est-ce qu'au final je te
rends compte que tout le monde peut être
vêtu un autre film du début 2010 comme
qui est non mais qui dans le fond le
n'est pas important ce qui est important
c'est le message derrière tout le monde
peut un qte hic tout le monde peut se
lever plus il y avait des images article
du partage et du monde dans des manifs
avec juste des c2 cutie puis tabarnak
que ça fait peur mais mettons pour
quelqu'un le qu'aucune de ces coins on
peut te faire un résumé de ce que c'est
queen ann woll équivalent annoncé une
conspiration
à la base c'est quelqu'un qui écrit sous
le pseudonyme qui m'anime
au début tu es sur forza et médor
principalement pour les animés japonais
à la base ça le budget basé sur tout fan
qui est un forum pour les dessins animés
japonais est quelqu'un crie fort tchane
c'est devenu quelque chose d'autre quand
lieu de liberté d'expression quasi
absolu
c'est le lieu de naissance de la culture
sélim beaucoup des mines que tu vois le
sont ou ont été créés la paix ensuite ça
fait son chemin ce raid est ensuite
facebook et twitter c'est vraiment c'est
une usine c'est une usine qui crée la
culture web moderne avec ses défauts
puis c'est bonne qualité il a aussi de
city est un endroit qui quand même
obscur de l'apport des gens vont pas
supporter tant pis le commun des mortels
les gens n'ont pas dit non pas de photo
de profil une fois de compte tout le
monde alors que l'ovni anonymous
multiples petites antilles avec un
certain identifiant bon y'a quelqu'un
qui a commencé publié le 28 octobre 2007
10 ans qui s'appelait ku dit écoutez en
gros c'est que le président europe est
en train de mener une guerre civile
secrète clandestine contre une cabale
satanique pédophiles qui contrôle non
seulement que vendre américain mais pas
mal le monde
pitié bien est-ce qu'on voit ça fait
tout partie d'un plan donc télé le chaos
semble émaner de la maison blanche
les tweets de chuck qui faute de la
zizanie dans l'actualité ça veut tout
parti n'est reparti tout se fera dans le
plan qui m'énerve store qui est un
évènement ou peint toutes les opposants
dans notre homme pour être emprisonné
sommairement envoyé devant des tribunaux
militaires soient exécutés ou soient
emprisonnés à cuba notamment en gros
c'est ça un pin
l'idée est que cette personne là
comme unique allied des réseaux sociaux
en haut des pistes paul chan fois
champion dit non c'est non merci
c'est quand même particulier parce que
forte gêne c'est un endroit qui est
reconnue pour la liberté d'expression
absolue ou quasi absolu puis finalement
il trichait pas trop ce qui nous attend
qpr ont commencé à prendre de l'envol ce
sont transférées chunks c'est vraiment
la liberté d'expression absolue c'est un
site qui est plusieurs tireurs qui ont
mis en direct et public jeune en direct
par exemple que je souhaite qu'une
modération
il y en aurait le s'exerce plus étrange
est devenue icône qu'il est encore pire
c'est hébergé proche du très bon mais je
pense qu'il fallait justement je pense
que les y est sur le trône est le même
ces deux hommes aux philippines qui ont
ce site ayant réussi à trouver des
services pour héberger le site qui leur
permit de d'accepter toutes sortes de
contenus c'est notre web c'est ce qui
est drôle c'est que si on en quittant le
mouvement qui se posent et non contre le
trafic d'enfants puis tout a lieu sur un
site web qui est notoire parce qu'il ya
de la vie qu'est ce qui fait qu'ils
aient mettons ce mouvement le s'est
démarqué de d'autres le maton pourquoi
qui devenu si groupe s'inquiète ainsi
c'est vraiment ce si ces ultimes en
fascinant pour rire parce qu'il y en a
eu d'ordi ku oui à lui d'autres des
prophètes tels le demi la petite
c'est vraiment une bonne analogie parce
que des études aient profitte comme
jésus en avait plein des profiteurs
politique qui disait pour jésus à poigne
et prône une raison non
même chose pour qt mais ça faisait
partie des gens de ce qu'ils appellent
les copies peste jean c'est comme le
monde raconte l'histoire de porsche a
écrit un texte assez d'étirer la faire
croire embarqué les gens n'attendent en
fait les gens qui lisent souvent savent
que c'est pas vrai mais qui peut se
raconter des histoires de parts de jeu
celle qui est probablement pas vu un
fantôme mais c'est le fun des histoires
l'heure c'est sabine chercher même chose
pour qu il y avait fbn anniversiare un
homme avait écrit en avance ça faisait
partie de la culture forte quand des
gens qui pour troller pour faire du shit
posting pour passer pour des agents
s'écrit à pi 10 po à paris le monde ni
sopi pas autre chose tu es cuit cet
appel ou joke mais le monde y occupe
c'est devenu bien beau temps et
sionistes patrese en fait quelqu'un qui
disait mot c'est fini je m'en vais il
lui vraiment réalisé l'endroit fait faux
gamme en vip ce quelqu'un d'autre qui a
jusqu'au 20 ans parce que l'identifiant
de trucs comme kit qui protégé par un
mot de passe
l'or continue à poster après le duo
gameiro 64 donc pas à moins que
quelqu'un a pris le vol de mots de passe
étaient postés sous la main il conclu
mais certainement qu en tant qu on fait
le tour de force chez natcan évoqué le
mandat de vérifier l'identité de
personnes ces deux sites complètement
différent ça génère pas le même
identifiant pile d'anti rechange et cinq
ou six fois aussi depuis qu'en italie
ray kunz a changé mais ça change aussi
une couple de fois qu'ils nous disaient
que de change de troll densifiant
n'importe où dans ce processus là
quelqu'un de puissant paris d'être seul
le qca tout le monde suit en ce moment
c'est une entente dans la communauté à
savoir ça c'est le vrai qui nous
inquiète mais y en a d'autres qui disent
qu'ils sont les vrais ku
mais c'est un phénomène qui est rendu
qui a énormément de momentum
donc j'ai trop de gens qui sont
énormément investis là à bout de ligne
on s'en fout c'est qu'il veut et qse
juste sur qui on s'entend pour dire que
c'est lui d'être ses deux pépites dsk je
comprends c'est que tous les
utilisateurs autre lehman participe
activement à ce que c'est plus comme un
leader c'est comme tout le monde met son
grain de sel puis c'est ça je pense
qu'il fait en grande partie si la
frénésie autour de qse xylophone pour
bien des gens c'est comme un jeu vidéo
en grandeur nature qui au début faisait
des prédictions très précises quand je
vous disais tantôt il était une voix et
après avoir été dans deux trois jours la
garde nationale déployés après un moment
il s'est mis à parler en énigmes qu'il
dit pu telle chose avait il dit il pose
des questions si dix escales et la
connexion entre ces personnes et cette
personne douée est ce que cette personne
ne vient d'acheter une maison si oui
elle vaut commun à quel point chaque
aftati parce que cette personne n'a
donné de l'argent qu'elle est la
connexion
dans le fond il y appelle ceux dans la
parlant de qui nous sommes tellement des
miettes que les gens doivent connectés
ensemble trouver eux mêmes
la solution à l'énigme ça c'est super le
fun pour bien des gens du des gens
passent des ordres d'ali sur le web
cherchait donc cesser participatif c'est
un plus mineur parce que le tout le
monde peut se reconnaître puis qui
transposé n'ai pas qualité l'idée dans
les années qui sont non seulement c'est
ce qui te le de l'approbation de la
communauté cité si toi tu réussis à
trouver la connexion est j'ai trouvé
j'ai trouvé une connexion de ce gala
puis un tweet de trempe de trois
semaines regarder plus mais une capture
d'écran le thé d'ilike des gens avec des
mélodies qui commence à partager ta
théorie plus tard troupe voit un telle
influence heures qui ont préféré
partager ta théorie ce cycle est issu
pas mais ça si c'est vraiment assez
addictif pour bien des gens de
participer à ce qui participe à un
mouvement plutôt que juste passivement
consommer des prophéties ccc vraiment
c'est vraiment de
cet élément-là de participation qui est
vraiment fort là dedans c'est vraiment
l'idée l'idée complètement une scène que
tu es admettons le je veux prendre forme
en page lointaine pour revenir à mon
idée mais quand est à la saison morte la
nbi et l'été passé il y eut un compte
twitter qui est arrivé qui prédisaient
les échanges où les signatures en se
disant lui-même étant dans l'entourage
de l'ex de la santé ou de la nbi un
genre 2 puis ça a commencé parce qu'il
fait une prédiction vraiment adhère
vraiment rindom qui s'est avéré vrai
plus y'a comme devant lyon photo michael
jordan au tie break avec le lit lui et
gagne vraiment un momentum deuxième
prédictions encore une fois de quoi
vraiment dire qu'ils aimeraient vraiment
me manquer c'est sûr que c'est une
personne proche de l'état-major des
lakers troisième prédictions
complètement dans le champ complètement
off pilote le monde ont juste arrêter le
suivais ça finit là l'espèce de 2 comme
de momentum l'été mais de penser que
crise des affaires vraiment qu'ils se
produisent pop des gardiens momentum à
quel point il faut quel point il faut
que tu veux raconter une histoire
l'image is le quiou de la nba plutôt que
de dire tel joueur a été changé pour tel
joueur il rédige un joueur un joueur
avec la lettre elle dans son nom le
rallye dans une ville où il fait froid
il aussi à la communauté de découvrir
piquante aux gens des milliers de gens
qui essaient de trouver une manie
quelqu'un va avoir raison
quelqu'un vous retrouvez la vraie vie de
l'otage a dit rétroactivement mais
regardez il le prédit alors que la
prison tant que test est proprement une
prédiction c'était une suggestion
le mécanisme de ce sujet nerfs devant
une situation des milliers de gens c'est
de traiter de trouver des prédictions
c'est le principe du jeu de bonne
aventure qui votent contre les 50 à
faire avoir raison sur une chose qui va
retenir la
la chose sur laquelle à leur examen
c'est drôle parce que des indices la
guerre de mouvement qui va tendre c'est
combien de combien de coïncidences avant
que ça devient inévitable que c'est vrai
mais c'est plutôt l'inversé que vous
générez tellement de contenu par jour
c'est inévitable
c'est une loi de la statistique tu vas
avoir raison trop de temps en temps
c'est sûr et certain
il est sûr et certain comment compost
mais qui demande remettront pas celle
d'un possible mais c'est drôle c'est
qu'on se comptent en millions bonne
question à travers le monde parce que là
on en voit partout il y avait une manif
cette fin de semaine en allemagne
j'ai fait une faute une grosse pancarte
de kew de des gens qui demandent
également j'ai vu une photo de mike
peine séparent les deux seuls des
yankees sont qtes au québec si chaque
fois que des manifestations mi mars qu
il ya des pans entiers de couillonnade
la première fois j'ai vu qu'ils ont
émergé dans la vraie vie au canada je
suis tombé en bas de ma chaise tête
pendant les manifestations de des gilets
jaunes à ottawa ou 2018
ouais j'ai jamais parlé publiquement de
kuoni à la radio ne pas alimenter les
eaux je voulais petit je voulais pas
écrire d'article voyait d'autres médias
ford explain assurent qu'ils honorent
chaque homme je veux pas donner notre
sujet mais quand c'est entrer dans la
vraie vie celle de quelqu'un mais ne
s'est passé quoi écrit dans google la
seule information qui trouve c'est sur
du contenu associé au mouvement faut que
tu sois là pour les gens qui se posent
des questions et se suit le mouvement
mettant qui fait le plus peur ou la
conspiration qui tissent et ça continue
prend de l'ampleur ça va devenir
inquiétant il ya un potentiel non
potentiel dangereux la date il ya déjà
eu des gens qui sont
et qui sont rentrés la contre la
conspiration
le papa de qui au nom de quelqu'un qui
rentre avec une carabine la pizza à
washington dc pour enquêter sur le
réseau satanique pédophiles devraient
lui clinton puis heureusement personne
personne n'était blessé mais genre sa
gloire réalisé par la suite que complet
a pas de bon sens mais on en voit de
plus en plus des choses comme ça des
gens que pendant la pandémie femmes à
new york qui a été arrêté en hystérie
elle avait un couteau à son aéroport de
new york pour enquêter sur le navire
hôpital de l'armée américaine qui
supposément servait à sortir des enfants
de la fondation louis clinton qui était
souvent colons bolt en voit plein de
gens là comme ça qui est qui
malheureusement tant d'inspiration pour
tout le monde cela étant dit qu'ils vont
tomber la date et qui mène que le niveau
de mobilisation de clown en est quand
même surprenant membres si le parallèle
je fais c'est black like the way les
gens il ya un homme droit que c'était
abattre par la police sont pas contents
sont des cendres se sont mobilisés sont
descendus dans les rues
lyon lyon sont encore dans les rues en
ce moment c'est un mouvement qui a eu un
impact réel sur la vraie vie en fait
changer des dérèglements d un changement
d'attitude ou cybill shepherd et jean y
avait des émeutes
tout est jeté rometty ya eu quand même
une mobilisation monte young croit que
des centaines de milliers d'enfants sont
tués par le parti démocrate
pis on vous ouais ils ont pas dans les
ruines les y en a eu en fait il y en a
eu la semaine dernière et la semaine
d'avant le save the children qui est
communiqué il commençait comment
justement aller chercher de nouveaux
auditoires
un faisan supposément des manifestations
contre le trafic d'enfants mais que la
fondation de ceux qui ont un métier
comment est-ce que tu peux vivre avec ça
tu penses vraiment que le parti
démocrate très fait des centaines de
milliers d'enfants chaque jour pitt
je faisais tout ce qui se passe est
postée sur le web si ya pas beaucoup de
mobilisations dans la vraie vie sont
interdits alimentaires pour l'instant
dit victime et on sent qu'on passe
justement des sectes qui ce qui en est
une
finalement pratiquement le titre le
potentiel de finir mal le détail des
sets qui finissent à un suicide de masse
où justement on prend les armes si
mettons ça continue prendre l'ampleur
puis à monique you écrit aujourd'hui on
prend les armes qui ont attaqué le
gouvernement
le partout dans le monde les assemblées
nationales sont attaqués par demande tu
essaies tu sais pas or la semaine passée
c'est ce qu'ils font ce qui c ku ce pas
en avant cette crise
non je m'excuse mais personne à personne
sa personne à une norme emv pour mais
oui cette personne disposons là ou là
mais d'élections d'ici les jeux ne sont
pas fiables énormément pouvoir pour
justement des centaines de milliers
voire des millions personnes donc quand
qui vous écrit quelque chose il ya le
monde ce fonds qui obame sur twitter par
exemple 6 kg ou partageant thé tout
était fait pour la journée le ferme son
compte twitter ce qui pêche par le monde
viennent juste dans tes mention petites
quilles ou 5 me qui ou saint denis qui
vous 7000 et là ça commence les insurgés
qui disent qu'un crétin qui se posent et
le cd fois qu'ils ouvrent à partager un
tweet pour une raison quelconque il va
dire regardez lyon par heure c'est
souvent un journaliste qui écrit un
article sur qui on en laisse comme garde
des petits tas par un journaliste sa vie
ruinée pour une semaine excepté soit un
niveau de mobilisation web c'est pas le
mode non sentant le mais est ce que ça
vaut mais on le voit déjà
pour le moment le mouvement qui votent
en masse côte ou au québec au canada
s'est greffée à d'autres mouvements t on
parce que de trop sentant que quand tu
vois des manifs anti mascles si pas
nécessairement la démographie qui vont
sur etienne nancy
non non non ils vont pas le même délai y
avait des groupes facebook est et queens
and planes ont permis de fermer big lots
de police s'est rendue sur les réseaux
sociaux les flops lingots est tout à
fait c'est parce qu'ils sont très actifs
ils vont trouver d'autres d'autres
façons jamais réussir à tout les trouver
ces groupes là mais sa sortie en fait
les lits groupe facebook c'est l'art est
une des raisons pourquoi ça s'trouve
espagne et ces mouvements là qui est
écrit sur des forums ont plus de gens
vont les adhérentes qui honore
aujourd'hui la vaste majorité ils vont
pas sourire comme les les messages vont
se fier à des sites qui archive les
postes de kew est un domaine qu'ils
disent probablement pas les postes de
kew mais sont dans la communauté parce
que tu sais quoi exactement la plupart
imagine le ticket c'est même peut
évidemment c'est comment ça fonctionne
et la majorité qui essaie de décrypter
concessions annoncées suisse fait partie
de leur mouvement qui se bat contre le
mal 115 défend les enfants
il ya de quoi de daïra pour bat déjà
perse à ces personnes est d'accord avec
le trafic d'enfants mais mentalement non
petit qu'un mouvement dit nous on est
content de trafic d'enfants des enfants
et des milliers d'enfants qui sont
abusés à chaque année nous on se bat
contre bbb oui je veux me battre contre
ces débris qui de sensé voudrait se
battre contre les trafics d'enfants
je pense explique beaucoup en partie
aussi le pôle l'explosion de popularité
dans certaines tranches la population
surtout des mères de famille et les amis
cherchent vraiment il ya quelque chose
qui veut faire mal à des enfants qui bat
pour les protéger est ce que c'est de là
que saviez la ferait quoi faire oui
c'est ça
amazon kaki hollande devient plus simple
faux plat maintenant vos des
manifestations d'autres ça que les gens
grande conspiration sans savoir qu'ils
participent à une conspiration du fer
routeur alors on nous accuse de trafic
d'enfants
aujourd'hui au lendemain on nous accuse
de trafic d'enfants
l'équipe si je joue pleinement partagée
selon l'histoire de fr pis sur ma peau
du monde sont activement la ligue mais
comme ceux qui réussissent à aller
chercher de nouveaux membres c'est que
yamani gens qui vont croire à cette
conspiration là une minorité de ces gens
là qui vont dire que je vais aller voir
plus loin et j'ai goûté la première dose
est ce que est ce que les enfants
mannequins sont égales aux supposés
infamant qu'un qu'est-ce que tu aimais
tant aimé ton qui sait des dizaines de
milliers d'enfants qui se font trafic
tramway presque images enfin c'est en
amérique du nord c'est que souvent et
ils vont sortir des statistiques comme
ça je connais pas les chiffres précis
mais oui en fait ils vont sortir des
statistiques comme on voudrait 130 mille
enfants par année sont très fier aux
etats-unis le teckel o'shea t-il 130 me
d'impact qui paraît se rend compte que
80 18 % du temps c'est au moment de la
famille c'est un beau père qui parle
avec l'enfant de la blonde ccso le cjd
qui traite de quelqu'un traversent une
frontière entre deux états unis sont un
trafic d'enfants selon la loi c'est donc
si ces projets le parti démocrate qui
poussent les enfants littéralement pas
ça m'était c'est sûr que tu peux trouver
des statistiques m'enfin j'attends
qu'ils vont venir un confirmé ce qu'est
ce que tu crois avant contre laisse
partir
admettons que c'est une question qu'on
se pose de plus en plus parce que de
plus en plus nos entourages on voit des
complots passé sur facebook
qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce qu'on
fait si quelqu'un qu'on estime qu'
proche de nous concert commence à
attendre vers ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
n'est pas évident vraiment pas évident
puisque c'est pas quelque chose il faut
que la personne va s'en sortir quelqu'un
puisse sortir de keenan par exemple il y
en a c'est arrivé mais c'est pas
vraiment que tu es toi-même ce que
disent qu'il faut faire enfoncer prendre
antique pas pour attaquer la personne en
public sur facebook dans les
commentaires ou thé le traité de con il
faut entretenir le dialogue en privé en
personne c'est encore mieux métier dans
message privé c'est vraiment si c'est
quelqu'un à qui soutient ces deux pôles
à laisser aller donc visuellement si un
facteur très important dans la défense
aux conspirations si tu vois quelqu'un
commence à sombrer là dedans c'est
justement football offre un défaut paul
les coupes et de s'éviter faut aussi
d'entretenir ses relations le parce que
cette personne va avoir besoin des gens
comme toi dans son entourage
malheureusement je sais que ce soit
difficile ou si on en entendait on aussi
des courriels de gens que leur logement
de la famille tomber dans qui ont
annoncé comme j'ai pu conversations avec
ma mère a fait jamais crier après parce
que chan dormi on entendit ce qu'on leur
dit c'est pas possible c'est vraiment
pas facile mais si cette personne
un jour il faut qu'elle ait des gens
dans son entourage qui sont le port et
le pis c'est pas vrai que si est le plus
d'amis qui sont plus dans le sont pas
dans kimono ou dans les conspirations
c'est surtout c'est comme c'est le même
phénomène avec des sectes que la
personne se rend dans une situation tous
ses amis toute sa famille sont dans
l'es7 quand vous s'en sortir les pas de
ressources donc c'est vraiment de
comprendre aussi de comprendre plus
qu'autre chose des poses des questions
plutôt que d avec des articles qui dit
direct par rapport la personne au pot
écouter vos politiques façon le
journaliste qui de l'article fait partie
de la conspiration
c'est de toute façon c'est vraiment pose
des questions pia c'est d'éveiller cette
question' mort à l'intérieur mais c'est
que c'est vraiment pas évident
honnêtement la personne le veut et
hellman vous sujet une question finale
deux questions finale
comment qu'on fait c'est quoi les trucs
pour s'assurer de la véracité de
l'information qu'on voit sur les réseaux
sociaux mettons le sait que c'est quoi
ces
évidemment vérifier les sources mêmes
attentes et plus largement la question
de lire l'article c'est lille se
prémunir contre consulte faut prendre le
temps donc la vitesse c'est ce qui tue
sur les réseaux sociaux
on est tous ceux qui on n'a pas le temps
de vérifier l'information ne bougeait
pas autant dire que toute l'information
que je laisse chaque jour un pis c'est
ma job de vérifier l'information donc je
mets 40 heures de plus que tout le monde
l'attend pour pour prendre la tête
honnêtement pis ce que j'aime dire aux
gens c'est que t'es pas obligé de
partager quelque chose si t'es pas son
partage les points s'est imposé d'une
personne c'est une photo qui vient de
manière puis certes il faut tout seul
qui ait pas d'article puis le mondial
qu'est ce qui s'est passé attend de voir
si c'est une vraie photo on va parler il
va avoir quelques d'autres n'ont pas
quelqu'un va enquêter sur la photo on
retrouve d'où ça vient pu avoir un vrai
article adultes y est t'as pas besoin de
partager de suite même si la photo choc
mines ses représentants dans l'opinion
t'es pas obligé de partager quelque
chose donc prend du temps c'est de
trouver d'autres sources qui par la même
chose
puis maintien si cette hausse des
questions ses doigts s'il provient
d'informations
comment est ce que la personne a obtenu
cette information là est ce que la
personne qui raconte ce semble
plausiblement avoir les compétences
nécessaires pour me parler
il ya une raison pourquoi les
journalistes quand on écrit un article
on dit selon telles personnes ont bien
senti être tués selon le professeur
intel pour parier il n'est ce pas pour
les fans c'est qu'on attribue
l'information on explique exactement
comme on l'a obtenu on dit pas
simplement il ya eu deux morts dans un
accident d'autocar on dit bosso ont dit
il ya une statue de mort selon la sûreté
du québec août selon le médecin traitant
ou à la vérité on dit tout le temps où
on obtenait d'autres informations
c'est pas parfait mais c'est au moins
quand il quand tu peux pas répondre à
ces questions le dans le fond quand tu
peux pas dire comment est ce que cette
personne note obtenue cette information
là est ce que cette personne mais est
compétent pour ces choses là mais c'est
l'opposé que c'est il faut mais ça
devrait allumer des lumières et roubaud
j'attends je vais attendre de voir
peut-être cette information-là va sortir
dans un autre contexte approprié c'est
souvent quand ce qu'on voit sur des
réseaux sociaux c'est des témoignages
des gens disent ils étaient 8 l affaire
complètement folle dans mon village où
tout est à un membre de ma famille si
pas fiable
mais si c'est vrai ils vont trouver
souvent vont trouver une manière de qui
c'est le poste va avoir de la traction
plus les journalistes vont contacter la
personne qui vont venir
donc c'est vraiment de prendre son temps
je pensais vraiment la meilleure chose à
faire
de quelle n'est pas obligé de partager
quelque chose
instantanément j'avais vu en écoutant
décryptage comment il y avait une
méthode qui maintenant que tu vois une
photo que tu doute la véracité pourrez
télécharger faire une recherche de cette
philosophie le voir où cette ou ces
photos elle était partagée
souvent ça arrive tu es tellement ni
femme au réal ouellet vers type les
tissus de recherche pistons new york en
2002 de tirs mais des photos c'est super
facile de détourner ce facile afin de
rechercher un ingénieur système chrome
ou firefox clic droit sur l'image
recherche google books va trouver toutes
les autres instances de cette photo de
son mobile c'est un peu plus compliqué
hein vous de la télécharger
je pense que je suis bing qui utilisent
nos méthodes de recherche inversée
fonctionne mais ouais c'est époux
même si mr pas accès à ce houthistes une
vidéo tu sais pas trop comment laver
phibun est tous des mots-clés toujours
une photo d'une manif wargo avec un
drapeau américain
souvent les gens vont trouver des photos
à leurs pigeons la republier donc c'est
encore une fois je m'attends pas à ce
que tout le monde est capable soit
capable de vérifier toutes mes sites pas
la réponse partage le prix avec photos
d'une manière fanti masque à montréal en
guise je mets des guillemets pour ceux
qui nous écoutent
en audio mes enfants il y avait
c'était se pose est à moriat piste est
supposé être ooyala archambault sur 55 4
int où il y avait les jambes où il y
avait la rambo métier comme l'espèce de
grosses bannière qui dit archambault
grosse un essai sauf que si on regarde
sa photo pi c'est quelque chose qui
vraiment semblable à ceux puis le mot
commence par c mais c'est jean raimbault
allemande impose ici la personne je suis
athée c'est même plus élevée climator
dernière question penses tu que c'est
une problématique mais tant les deux
formations pile la montée du
conspirationnisme et quitte assez
sérieuse pour que mettons les
gouvernements fassent de coin qu'est-ce
qui pourrait fermer ton juste via un
bureau du fbi à phoenix a déclaré menace
potentielle aux états unis et en partant
avec toutes les habitudes et
l'association qui a la double
dispositions sont pas capables de
trouver ces qui mettons puis je m'en
sers très franchement probablement là ça
y est c'est qu'il sait mais la passe et
que rien fait d'illégal je le droit
d'inventer un personnage qui publié ce
week end ne veut pas rentrer là dedans
mais ça me surprendrait qu'ils ne savent
pas c'est qu'il est surtout et sherritt
kunz et pas des sites qui sont ces
coeurs l'hôpital il ya plein de vie
plein d'experts en sécurité informatique
qui disent matiz c'est la preuve qui
n'est pas un agent secret parce que
l'agent secret diviseraient pas une
plateforme où ce père sécurité it shine
pour publier des messages chaque
résident donc peut-être qu'ils savent je
sais pas où est ce que ça va mener c'est
sûr que il ya peut-être des gens qui
vont faire des actes violents
au nom de qui ou non mais c'est pas un
groupe il n'y a pas de leader il ya pas
de membership ne sait pas on n'est pas
dans l'époque ce sont des groupes
vraiment restreint avec délice comment
ça ressemble en fait l'homme
mais vraiment - organiser des
indicateurs allez allez chercher vos
vieux dvd les 1,92 à les comprendre le
web
mais au québec qui eux
catherine fournil qu'interpeller le
françois legault l'outil hands l'état si
c'est que ce cabinet 35 % des québécois
pensent qu'elle aimait les médias
traditionnels répandre de fausses
nouvelles
18 pour sa pensée le carnet virus a été
créé par les gouvernements pour nous
contrôler 1 18%
c'est rare book ou le thé basij art
qu'est ce qui compte c'est ce qui fait
qu'en bas ces propos içki pauvres des
quizz qui devrait pas de quoi ce qui
s'est encore une fois j'aime pas trop
idyllique van damme ans qui rentre dans
le contrôle de l'information n'est
fondamentalement petit c'est la raison
pourquoi on aime pas trop aussi que les
gouvernements décident qui est qui et
par journalistes ça devient une histoire
que ça devient un sujet qui est
énormément et minorités généralement les
médiums s'autoréguler de cette façon là
donc comme par exemple les journalistes
qui vont la tribune d'après et son
parlement mais c'est un groupe de médias
qui a le droit d agir c'est pas le
gouvernement qui dit tel média tel média
d'ailleurs il ya eu 10 les controverses
pendant la dernière élection d'entre eux
doit décider que tel blog avait pas
droit d'envoyer un journaliste alors
point de presse tout terrain c'est pas
une bonne idée quand gouvernement ce qui
est vrai qu est-ce qui est pas vrai
puisque commencé à jouer là-dedans c'est
ce sont les gouvernements veulent mettre
en place des programmes d'éducation
médias par exemple
ouais guzzi parfait donner des
ressources et des ressources aux médias
pour qu'ils puissent faire leur travail
s'ils veulent encadrer les réseaux
sociaux de façon peu plus serré
peut-être tout mais vraiment de se
mettre à jouer à ça c'est vrai c'est pas
vrai ce serait très de 56 ans est
peut-être
peut être que dans le futur se serait tu
es avec les réseaux sociaux sans n'iront
probablement nulle part fait peut-être
que l'idée c'est de faire découvrir ce
qui est enceinte comment décrypter les
informations commencent à comment savoir
reconnaître une information qui fausse
piste d'un jeune en jeudi au secondaire
je met son art et 4 du monde qui qui qui
reçoivent secours le tuer à savoir
comment comment discerner les chaussures
j'ai participé à l'élaboration d'un
projet s'appelle 30 secondes avant d'y
croire c'est un projet où les
journalistes vont dans les écoles
secondaires parler de fausses nouvelles
de 28 ans cours du nord sur le tout
c'est pourquoi la désinformation existe
des petits trucs pour comment les
repérer mais c'est vraiment plus
plutôt qu'un cours d'éducation aux
médias c'est plus une sensibilisation
d'enfants 30 secondes avant d'y croire
qu'il faut prendre au moins 35 ans d'âge
est quelque chose d tantôt que jeudi de
prendre le temps avant de rentrer c'est
vraiment ça peut sonner mettant sa garde
à vue le temps de lire l'article était
spears oct
on manque 35 10 t'as pas lu l'article
karmapa lula mais mi temps mais d'une
dizaine de milliers d'élèves je pense la
kozah pandémie je pense le projet sera
aux métis ya des gens qui nous écoutent
qui sont professeurs de seconde à ce
programme qui s'adresse aux cinq ans à 4
et 5 dont 2 630 30 ans chief seconde
pluriel point d'orgue faut inscrire
votre place
on va vous marchez avec un journaliste
quand ce sera possible le
je pense que ça sera pas pour la rentrée
d'automne mais on essaye idéalement par
contre ce serait bien que ça se fasse
partie du cursus scolaire et non des
gens et les volontaires qui font ça sur
leur propre terre
une première démarche romaine se sont
dites cassantes
d'éducation d'information ça fait partie
des citoyens de savoir comment
départager le vrai du faux
séné ce soir puis si on écoute
décrypteurs nous aide à comprendre
[Rires]
puis je suis désolé pour lui commente
aussi attend aussi atteint à chaque fois
qu'on parle de ces choses là les
bénéfices et qui arrive en gagne parce
que à mener ont lancé en mettant au
l'entreprise peut-elle pas dire c'est
que les formations ont adressé un petit
peu le 5 g pour le mit dans le titre
fait qu'au début c'est juste que mes
bonnes conversations les gueux avec avec
olivier super intéressant il amène une
semaine après une semaine et demie plus
tard on reçoit une notification le comme
de l'eau de monde qui vont vous être des
crises de moutons et ce type i puis ça
va arriver dans le même après-midi à 5,6
sont arrivés effectifs clairement y sont
passé le mot de quelque part je dirais
qu'on est apte à goutte